[Musique]
Caroline Galacter Rose, bonsoir.
Bonsoir. Nous vous recevons pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle
Sinkerview. Nous sommes en direct.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ? Très succintement. Très
succintement. Je suis docteur en
sciences
politiques. J'ai longtemps travaillé
pour les services de l'État. Quel type
de service ? les services du Premier
ministre qui aujourd'hui s'appelle le
SGDSN pendant une dizaine d'années.
Après, j'ai enseigné, je suis entrée
dans la réserve opérationnelle des
armées, j'ai fait beaucoup de choses
différentes et
aujourd'hui euh je dirige un petit sing
tank qui s'appelle qui est consacré à la
géopolitique réaliste et qui s'appelle
Géopragma. Et j'ai créé il y a un peu
plus d'un an chaîne YouTube qui
s'appelle Pegger.
Donc vous êtes YouTubeuse. Je suis une
YouTubeuse. Absolument. Et ben écoutez,
on est content de vous recevoir après 6
ans. On s'était déjà reçu il y a 6 ans.
C'est vrai. On va parler de
géopolitique, on va parler de guerre
économique, on va parler renseignement,
on va parler psyops, on va parler
ingérence, on va parler Russie, Ukraine,
Amérique, Trump et monsieur Barreau
peut-être histoire de de nous égayer
dans l'asphyxie.
Caroline Galacteros, comment vous
percevez l'élection de Trump et comment
vous avez perçu
la comment je peux vous formuler ça ?
Comment vous avez perçu l'anticipation
de l'élection de Trump ? L'anticipation
de de des Européens ? Alors nous on a
rien anticipé. Nous on a c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire on a on a on en
mourrait on mourait de peur. Les
Européens mouraient de peur à l'idée que
Trump l'emporte et il l'a emporté malgré
tout.
Donc aujourd'hui, on est à on est à
cont-temps en fait de ce que fait grosso
modo la nouvelle administration
américaine, même si les choses sont plus
compliquées qu'on ne le dit et s'il est
le Trump numéro 2 2.0 est malgré tout
encore entouré de gens qui n'ont pas
forcément ces idées ou ses envies, du
moins en politique internationale. Donc
moi, j'ai vu ça plutôt comme une
opportunité de sortir un peu de la NASE
idéologique folle dans laquelle on était
entraîné, notamment nous les Européens,
mais on le fait de manière très
consentante, c'est moins qu'on puisse
dire, avec l'ancienne administration
Biden et notamment sur la
guerre contre la Russie, enfin entre
l'OTAN et la Russie via l'Ukraine. Et
voilà. Donc moi, j'ai vu ça comme une
occasion de faire du neuf. Alors avant
de voir l'occasion de faire du neuf,
comment vous expliquez ce manque
d'anticipation, ce manque de
perception et comment vous vous
expliquez la
la le choc de nos journalistes, de nos
prospectivistes, de nos gens de
politique ? Comment vous en comment vous
percevez ça ? C'est dû à quoi
? C'est du déni ? C'est du on veut pas
voir, c'était du impossible, c'est ils
prennent pas bien la température,
comment se passe ? Mais c'est un c'est
un c'est une c'est un alliage de tout un
tas de défauts, de tout un tas de
travers. Donc oui, il y a un déni massif
mais il y a un déniel. Nous ne vivons
pas dans le réel en fait en Europe. Nous
ne vivons clairement pas dans le réel.
Bon, ensuite, nous vivons avec des
fantasmes, des rêves d'enfants, des
rêves complètement enfantins de gloire
passée.
Alors, de gloire passée, oui. Euh de
mensonge sur l'état dans lequel nous
sommes, oui. et surtout pendant très
longtemps d'arrimage
volontaire, décisif,
méthodique, permanent sur ce que
souhaitait ce que ce coordonnait à vrai
dire Washington. Donc sur les questions
internationales, on en fait on est on
est on est des bébés, on est on est des
on est des enfants en fait en matière de
d'analyse et de d'anticipation plus
encore géopolitique parce qu'en fait on
a renoncé, on s'est on s'est coupé les
bras, les jambes pendant très longtemps.
Maintenant, on est face à un choc
considérable. Non seulement le choc du
reste du monde et du réel qui ne nous
attend pas et auquel nous ne comprenons
rien, mais même ce choc du divorce ou du
moins de
l'abandon en tout cas en ce moment et de
l'abandon par notre par notre parrain,
par notre mentor, par par l'Amérique et
on ne comprend rien, on ne comprend
absolument rien à ce que veut faire
cette nouvelle administration et surtout
à ce que souhaite faire Donald Trump et
on fait de la résistance très
bêtement à mon avis de manière
totalement contre-productive pour
nous-mêmes européens et je parle même
pas des pays les prix les uns parce que
l'Europe c'est encore c'est aussi une
utopie donc d'une certaine manière en
tout cas en terme de
géopolitique et de et d'autonomie
stratégique en dépit de tout ce qu'on
raconte. Donc euh on est on est dans un
espèce de de trou noir si vous voulez.
On est dans des sables mouvants et on
réagit euh pathétiquement.
Ces sables mouvants. Euh est-ce que vous
pouvez mettre des mots dessus ?
Sables mouvant par rapport alors je vais
prendre le dossier qui quand même
m'occupe et occupe beaucoup qui est le
dossier ukrainien. On est on est on est
englouti par nos propres paroles, par
nos propres promesses toutes plus
irréalistes les unes que les autres. Bah
de d'aller continuer à à nourrir, à
fourbir nos armes contre la
Russie. Pourquoi ? On ne sait pas. Bah
défendre les Ukrainiens d'une invasion
russe. Ouais mais là non là on défend
pas les Ukrainiens. On les envoie encore
plus et de manière encore plus certaine
à la mort. parce que tant qu'on tant
qu'on fait comment dirais-je non pas du
sur place mais même marche arrière par
rapport à tout ce qui est proposé par
Trump et là encore il y aurait a il y a
des nuances he parce qu'il y a plusieurs
canaux de négociation il y a plusieurs
écoles américaines actuelles dans
l'administration présente sur ce qu'il
convient de faire et ils s'entendent pas
tous donc c'est déjà compliqué en soi
mais nous on a décidé que ce n'était pas
concevable parce qu'en fait On ne veut
pas sortir de nos postures, on ne veut
pas perdre la face, on ne on considère
qu'on doit continuer à aider l'Ukraine à
mourir en fait.
Et oui, parce qu'on l'aide pas à se
défendre, on l'aide pas à devenir plus
forte en en poursuivant la guerre
pendant encore 1 an 2 ans avancé.
Non non, parce que l'avancée ça c'est
encore une
autre un autre mensonge initial qui a
fait je avant avant de dire le mensonge
initial.
Est-ce que vous aviez anticipé la guerre
avec les Russes ? Non. Pourquoi non ?
depuis le Donbas ce que j'ai ce que j'ai
vu en décembre 21 et ce à quoi j'ai
accorder beaucoup d'importance mais
manifestement on n'était pas très
nombreux à le faire, c'est les documents
qu'avaient envoyé pour moi ça ça a été
vraiment le signe les documents
qu'avaient envoyé Vladimir Poutine le 17
décembre 2021 à l'OTAN à Bruxelles, à
Washington
proposant d'arrêter en fait la montée à
la guerre
qui qui voilà la montée la montée de la
tension qui devenait difficilement
maîtrisable d'un côté comme de l'autre
et de refonder la sécurité européenne.
Donc et c'est toujours son sujet et
c'est toujours son
sujet et donc de c'est ce qui veut
laisser transparaître.
Oui, mais c'est c'est le sujet, c'est
pour ça qu'il est contraint. C'est c'est
le
feu total mais que personne ne respecte
à vrai dire parce que le CC le feu sur
les infrastructures énergétiques, il est
violé et maintenant il y a le décompte
qui a été fait. Euh comment et quand euh
le le je parle du cesser le feu sur les
infrastructures énergétiques
ukrainiennes qui a été décidé par les
Américains et les Russes mais que les
Ukrainiens enfin pour lequel les
Ukrainiens ne se sont pas sentis tenus
en fait. Euh et donc il est violé euh et
là la liste vient
d'être montrée par les Russes, par la
partie russe.
Euh donc voilà, il y a pas de cesser le
feu. Donc c'est c'est là c'est pas les
Russes qui le violent, c'est les
Ukrainiens. Et il vient à expiration, je
crois le 17.
Donc la question c'est est-ce que la
Russie va dire bon on continue ou est-ce
que on profite du fait que les
Ukrainiens l'ont violé clairement pour
relancer nos attaques sur les
infrastructures énergétiques
ukrainiennes qui sont déjà
extrêmement entamé et abîmé je crois aux
alentours de 70 %.
Donc ça c'est une chose en mer noire.
Là, c'est les Européens qui ont empêché
les Américains de mettre en place un
accord qui avait été discuté avec Moscou
dans les premiers pour parler he ce de
Riade 1
2 pour le
transport de marchandises agricoles et
d'engrais russes, ce qui nécessitait une
levée des sanctions européennes pour une
réintégration de la Russie dans des
mécanismes de
compensation pour pouvoir se faire payer
en fait leurs
exportations. Là, les Européens ont dit
non. Donc il il s'oppose clairement à ce
que veut faire Donald Trump. Et Donald
Trump, lui, il voit très au-delà, si
vous voulez, euh du point de vue
américain. Lui, il pense aux intérêts
américains et son idée, c'est d'en finir
avec cette guerre qui est perdue
militairement, clairement et depuis
longtemps. Et depuis longtemps et qui
est en fait une une humiliation. Est
perdu pour qui ? pour les Ukrainiens. Ah
bah pour les Ukrainiens, mais derrière
aussi pour l'OTAN, derrière aussi pour
les États-Unis, derrière aussi pour les
Européens. Sauf que nous nous faisons
comme si on avait rien perdu du tout,
comme si l'Ukraine pouvait encore
l'emporter, comme s'il s'agissait juste
de la fournir encore en armement pour
qu'elle tienne le choc pendant encore
des années pour
maintenir cette
hostilité contre la Russie, ce qui est
géopolitiquement un suicide. Essayez,
essay essayez, on va faire une
expérience de pensé tous les deux.
Essayez de penser contre vous-même.
Ouais. euh essayer d'être bienveillant
avec la politique d'Emmanuel Macron, de
l'Europe et ainsi de suite et et est-ce
qu'on peut se dire qu'ils essayent
d'avoir une même la une
stratégie déviée d'une stratégie de
guerre froide, c'est-à-dire épuiser la
Russie, c'est-à-dire continuer à mettre
des flots de sanction pour épuiser
l'économie russe, épuiser la l'armée
russe, épuiser, épuiser, épuiser et
ensuite pouvoir négocier.
Euh alors 1, c'est très mal connaître la
mentalité russe. C'est quoi la mentalité
russe ? La mentalité russe, c'est qu'il
y a des intérêts
nationaux russes, des intérêts
culturels, des intérêts stratégiques,
des intérêts vis-à-vis du reste de
l'Europe, vis-à-vis de l'OTAN, des
intérêts à reprendre langue et à
dialoguer avec l'Amérique. Et
là, le changement d'interlocuteur permet
d'envisager cela, même si les Russes
sont manifestement extrêmement prudents
et méfiants, on va dire.
Euh donc c'est très mal connaître la
Russie, c'est très mal connaître l'état
de l'économie russe, c'est très mal
comprendre en fait que nous avons
accéléré le renforcement de la Russie
par notre attitude notamment depuis 3
ans. Il faut dire par les sanctions par
les sanctions euh par euh par cette
hostilité qui a fait que la Russie a dû
reconsidérer euh son positionnement et
et s'en est s'est servi de cette guerre,
non seulement pour développer des
productions substitutives, en fait,
développer sa propre agriculture, sa
propre industrie, sa propre elle a
développé son
économie finalement pour pouvoir
soutenir cet effort de guerre. Qu'est-ce
qu'il fallait faire ? Il fallait laisser
les Russes enfoncer l'Ukraine comme dans
du beurre. Non non non, il fallait ne
pas préparer cette guerre depuis 2014.
Voilà. Parce que c'est quand même ça le
sujet. On dit que la guerre a commencé
le 24 février 2022. Non, elle n'a
évidemment pas commencé le 24 février
2022. Ce qui s'est passé, c'est la
réaction russe militaire et l'entrée
effectivement de force russes sur le
territoire ukrainien. Ça c'est
incontestable.
mais en comment dirais-je en réaction
alors d'abord en réaction à une
offensive qui était plus qu'en
préparation qui avait débuté le 16 qui
était la reprise du Donbas par les
forces ukrainiennes qui elles-mêmes sont
entraînées depuis le coup d'état de
Maidane depuis 2015. Nous entraînons les
formes les forces ukrainiennes en 2014
quand je dis on je parle de l'OTAN.
On vous voit mal sur le terrain au
tray. On vous voit mal sur le terrain au
tray en train d'entraîner les Ukraines.
Ah moi non. Quand je dis oui enfin c'est
pas les Russes ils avaient quand même
pris la Crimée. Non. Alors les Russes
ont pris la Crimée avant tout à fait
enfin avant dans la foulée de Maidan.
Pourquoi ? Parce que il y a la flotte et
on savait très bien ce qu'on faisait. On
savait très bien ce qu'on faisait. Mais
nous les occidentaux. nous les
occidentaux parce que cet Occident qui
aujourd'hui est
fracturé à l'intérieur si vous voulez
entre le pôle européen et maintenant
l'Amérique qui a qui a chifté
géopolitiquement en tout cas
partiellement euh nous étions à l'époque
beaucoup
plus comment dirais-je dans un dans un
mécanisme de cohésion bien plus forte.
C'est-à-dire que l'Europe obéissait
clairement via l'OTAN mais pas seulement
via l'OTAN aux États-Unis. Donc on était
tous d'accord pour pour ce qu'on a fait,
pour ce qui s'est fait à Maidan. Et à
partir de là, ça a permis de commencer à
former, à entraîner, à équiper, à
conseiller, à enfin bref, à créer une
armée ukrainienne suffisamment forte
comme en même temps notre antirussisme
primitif qui est quand même très répandu
en Europe et qui enfin qui qui est le
résultat bah déjà de la méconnaissance
de ce qu'est la Russie depuis la fin de
l'URSE, enfin Enfin, c'est un long
processus de délitement intellectuel et
de nos capacités de compréhension même
d'un adversaire, même si on considéit
que la Russie est un adversaire, comme
on ne la comprend pas, comme on la
sous-estime, comment on la méprise,
comme on ne veut pas admettre ce qui se
passe, comme par ailleurs, on ne veut
pas non plus admettre qu'il y a une
bascule du monde qui s'est produite dès
le début de la décennie 2010, on va
dire.
Moi, j'en parle depuis 10 ans, j'ai
l'impression de radoter complètement. Je
bien. Bon euh donc il y a cette bascule
du monde. Donc aujourd'hui quand on a
les Européens euh et nos propres
autorités euh qui explique qu'il s'agit
encore de d'abattre et de finir par
arriver à affaiblir la Russie et à la
fin à faire tomber cette cet
épouvantable dictateur qui est Vladimir
Poutine, euh on se dit que on a on a
rien appris, on a on apprend rien.
on continue à répéter les mêmes choses
et on continue à ignorer ce qui se passe
et on ne comprend pas non plus que la
Russie n'est pas
seule parce que c'est c'est aussi l'un
des effets délétaires de notre politique
dans ce conflit depuis 3 ans mais
j'allais dire bien avant depuis une
petite dizaine d'années maintenant 2014
myan bon c'est que on a on a
contribué a poussé d'une certaine
manière les autorités de Moscou à
reconfigurer leurs alliances et à et à
se lier beaucoup plus fermement,
beaucoup plus étroitement avec les
Chinois mais aussi avec l'Iran. Et aussi
ça aussi c'est un effet délétaire qu'on
ne mesure absolument pas. Il y a une
exemplarité. C'est c'est indicible ce
que je dis, mais c'est clair pour moi.
C'est très clair. Il y a une exemplarité
russe qui fait, j'allais dire école à
l'échelle du monde. Sur sur quel ? sur
le fait que c'est un pays qui a démontré
qu'il était capable de
résister à la pression de l'OTAN, des
États-Unis, de la Grande-Bretagne, des
Européens, de toute cette partie du
monde qui soi-disant dirigeait la
planète et qui ne la dirige juste plus.
Le monde a complètement chiffé,
complètement changé. Donc soit on ouvre
enfin les yeux, on tire certaines
conclusions, on revient sur certaines de
nos erreurs et de nos mauvais calculs,
on prend la réalité militaire telle
qu'elle
est, telle qu'elle est et on cherche à
finir ce conflit et on et on appuie en
fait ce que cherche à faire Donald
Trump.
On on appuie un accord, on appuie la
conclusion d'un accord, on on arrête le
massacre en Ukraine. Enfin, il y a quand
même entre 1000 et 1500 morts jour en
Ukraine. Est-ce que c'est ça aider
l'Ukraine ? Pendant ce temps, les forces
russes avancent, elles grignotent
jusqu'aux frontières des quatre blastes
qu'elles ont déjà intégré. Ils perdent
des hommes aussi eux. Ah ben bien sûr,
ils perdent des hommes, mais je ne crois
pas qu'il les perdent du tout dans les
mêmes proportions que les pertes
ukrainiennes. On parle quand même tous
les analystes. C'est bien mais les
sources c'est mieux. Alors les sources,
je vais vous dire mes sources, elles
sont pas russes. En tout cas pas
directement, elles sont euh
anglo-saxonnes à vrai dire puisque moi,
j'écoute, je sais pas une bonne dizaine,
douzaine de
d'analystes qui sont soit britanniques,
soit américains pour la plupart. euh
généralement d'anciens militaires,
généralement eux-mêmes en lien avec euh
d'autres militaires, soit qui sont sur
le terrain parce qu' il y en a sur le
terrain hein, il y a pas que des
Ukrainiens sur le terrain de l'Ukraine
euh même s'il y a pas de force
officielle euh
étrangère. Euh euh et donc tous ces
gens-là eux-mêmes, ils récoltent
énormément d'informations, ce que je ne
fais pas évidemment. Et donc eux quand
même, il y a un consensus et le
consensus anglo-saxon en fait qui de
temps en temps transparaît même dans la
dans la presse anglo-saxonne de temps en
temps quelques
articles euh c'est que en gros le ratio
il est allez si je suis très gentille en
terme de mort c'est de 1 à 6 et si je
vais vers les plus extrémistes de ces
analystes c'est d'un à 10 les Ukrain
disent quelle proportion à eux, ils
disent qu'il y a 700000 morts russes.
Donc entre 600 et 700000 morts russes.
Donc bon voilà. Mais c'est ce qu'il
c'est ce qui c'est ce qui c'est ce qu'il
cherche à dire. Il cherche à dire aussi
qu'ils se sont battus depuis 3 ans mais
que en face ça a sérieusement ils ont
pris des dégelés les Russes quand même.
Ah bah ils ont pris plein de dég mais je
ne dis pas le contraire. Je dis
simplement que la manière de mener la
guerre, je parle même pas des moyens
parce que là il y a eu aussi quand même
assez vite après un début difficile, il
y a eu une montée en puissance militaire
russe qui a
laissé estomaquer beaucoup d'analystes.
Si vous permettez,
vous avez déjà été en OPEX ? Oui, bien
sûr. Où ça ? Dans les Balcans ? Dans les
Balcans ? Combien de temps ? quelques
semaines pour plusieurs fois. Quel
objectif ? Je vais pas vous raconter
toute ma vie. Vous avez une formation
crapautage militaire ou juste d'an ?
Non, je suis pas je crapaute pas. Non
non, je suis un j'ai été j'ai été versée
dans en fait ce que j'ai fait je ce que
j'ai fait je l'ai pas fait en tant que
militaire d'ailleurs. Je l'ai fait en
tant que civil puisque j'étais civile
quand je travaillais dans les services
du premier ministre. Je suis rentré dans
la réserve opérationnelle des armées
après. Colonel de réserve encore ou vous
avez vous êtes sorti ? Euh je n'ai plus
d'affectation depuis
2022. Voilà, c'est tout. C'est tout ce
que je peux dire. Les balcons, les
balcans puisque je m'occupais de
l'évaluation de la prospective, de
l'analyse de tout le conflit Yougoslave
entre 92 et 2001. Les Serbes, ils en
gardent une certaine renqueur. Non, les
Serbes gardent une énorme ranqueur. Un
énorme Oui, c'est plus que de la
ranqueur. C'est de la c'est du C'est de
la tristesse aussi. C'est du ça a été la
manière dont là aussi mais
c'était il faut comprendre ce que
c'était que cette époque la décennie des
années 90 a été une
décennie extrêmement importante et
unique à vrai dire qui a vu complètement
changer une première fois l'ordre
international de la guerre froide tout
simplement avec la fin de l'URS avec le
début de l'intégration de t de tous les
anciens satellites soviétiques
à la fois dans l'OTAN et et dans l'Union
européenne. La volonté des peuples. Oui,
la volonté des peuples bien sûr. Enfin,
on l'aide la volonté des peuples. Bon,
mais ça ne veut pas dire orange pour ça
d'ailleurs. Non.
Ah c'est Ah c'est vrai, j'ai pas pensé
j'ai pas pensé à cette à la symbolique
de cette couleur. Oui. Euh
mais euh donc c'est c'est une décennie
très importante et c'est une décennie
surtout où commence à s'installer
l'unipolarité.
C'est-à-dire qu'à l'époque la Russie est
à terre et elle va le rester quand même
un bon 10
ans. La Russie est à terre, elle ne peut
pas réagir et elle ne réagit pas
d'ailleurs. Elle ne réagira pas à ce qui
va se passer en 1999 lorsque l'OTAN
bombardera de sa propre initiative sans
mandat de l'ONU, sans rien. Et moi
j'étais au première loge pour tout ça.
Je l'ai vu, je l'ai voilà. Vous étiez à
Belgrade ? Non, non, j'étais j'étais euh
j'étais là où j'étais, mais je je
connais ce conflit vraiment par le menu,
si vous voulez depuis le début et
jusqu'à la fin, voilà, jusqu'à fin 2001.
Donc euh donc on a bien on a on a décidé
que la Serbie était cette puissance
récalcitrante en fait de
l'époque et ce pouvoir récalcitrant
qu'il
fallait qu'il fallait mettre au pas et
mettre au pli. Voilà. et et ça s'est
fait alors sous divers prétextes. le
Kosovo en a été
[Musique]
un et et ce qui s'est passé en Bosnia
Zegovine et très largement mais là on
peut si vous voulez on peut en parler
mais ce qui s'est passé au moment de la
reconnaissance de la Bosnière Zégovine
de la Croatie de la Slovénie puis de la
Bosnie c'est en fait que l'Europe
elle-même du fait de la fin de l'URS et
du fait de la réunification allemande a
vu tous ces
mécanismes d'équilibre des pouvoirs et
des nations. européenne entre elles
bouleversé et notamment le rapport entre
la France et l'Allemagne. Et à ce
moment-là, il y a eu un il y a eu un
transfert de charge et de pouvoir en
fait vers l'Allemagne. Alors si je vous
réunifier, je vous coupe et la France a
suivi. Vous voulez continuer un petit
peu sur les balcans ou peut non ? Non,
j'aurais tant dire on va y revenir après
si vous avez on a le temps. C'est gros
avantage grâce à notre communauté qui
nous finance. C'est ça. Comme on prend
pas la YouTube
monnaie, ça ça nous empêche pas d'être
hyper indépendant et de traiter autant
de minutes de sujet et en toute
indépendance. Revenons, revenons à
l'Ukraine. Si je vous entends, si je
vous écoute, si je cherche à vous
comprendre, on aurait poussé l'Ukraine
vert. Mais bien sûr. Mais pourquoi alors
? Quelle est votre clé de lecture, votre
clé de voûte votre qui qui légitimerait
le fait qu'on pousse l'Ukraine à Mais
parce que l'Ukraine comme la Geéorgie
était les derniers états et on a essayé
en Geéorgie, ça n'a pas marché. En
2008, l'Ukraine était le le le si vous
voulez le containement de la Russie n'a
jamais cessé, il n'a pas cessé en 91 en
français le le le fait
de d'entourer de contraintes. Pardon ?
Oui. La contention. Oui, ça fait un peu
bas contention mais oui oui, c'est vrai.
Bon, la enfin en tout cas le fait de de
d'entraver la Russie, de l'empêcher de
la de la contrôler en fait, de la de
limiter son développement possible et de
limiter aussi ses liens avec l'Europe
d'ailleurs et on verra ça ça nous mène à
Nordstream et à tout ce qui s'est passé
depuis. Mais tout ça, c'est une vieille
politique, très ancienne politique qui a
plus d'un siècle à vrai dire qui a plus
d'un siècle. qui est une politique qui
qui est d'ailleurs une
politique qui a nourri alors britannique
bien sûr puis américaine. Enfin c'est
c'est la lutte des empires. C'est c'est
vieux j'allais dire c'est vieux comme
Hérode mais pas tout à fait mais c'est
très ancien. Donc à partir du moment où
l'URS est
tombée, enfin plutôt elle s'est délité
de l'intérieur à cause de bah à cause de
la course aux armements, à cause à cause
de ses propres faiblesses. Oui, bien
sûr. la corruption, le le le système
lui-même qui qui n'était plus viable,
qui ne tenait plus et aussi les
illusions d'un Gorbatchev qui s'est
imaginé qu'il allait pouvoir réformer
l'économie en tenant le système
politique. Bon, c'était d'une immense
naïveté. On a joué avec ça. Bon, très
bien. Bon, on est arrivé à faire en
sorte que ça s'effondre.
Euh politique de surarmement des deux
côtés bien sûr, mais ça voilà, Rigan
avait avait donné une impulsion je pense
assez
décisive. Euh et donc
euh il y a il s'est passé tout ça, mais
la politique de containement ne s'est
pas arrêtée là. C'est pas parce que l'UR
s'était effondré qu'on a décidé que on
l'a laissait tranquille. Non, on l'a
pénétré, on l'a infiltré, on a cherché à
la piller d'ailleurs dès les années 90.
Et le pouvoir de l'époque de Boris
Yelsin s'est quand même
prêté largement à ce
jeu-là. Et puis on a lancé le double
élargissement de l'OTAN et de l'Union
européenne pour récupérer au maximum.
Donc pour en revenir à l'Ukraine,
l'Ukraine stratégie mais mais bien sûr
si la Russie et la Chine deviennent dans
les 20 prochaines années très agressifs,
ils l'ont anticipé. Ils ont fait la
technique du bois constrictor, c'est ils
ont ils ont entouré la Russie et la
Chine de base navale, de tout un
contingent militaire pour pouvoir la
contenir. Dans l'anticipation, il
pourrait devenir des concurrents et
devenir béliqueux avec nos propres
sociétés. Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
Moi je pense que la
planète permet d'exister à tout le monde
à vrai dire et que ce qu'il y avait de
bien pendant la guerre froide couleur.
Ouais, je suis sûr de je suis sûr en
terme de ressources tout va bien. Non
mais je veux dire non mais après la
surpopulation c'est un autre sujet
d'exploitation.
Bah oui, je pense que on peut très bien
il faut arriver à discuter et à
dialoguer avec tout le monde. On ne peut
pas
juste, j'allais dire planifier la
disparition des uns ou des autres parce
qu'ils nous gênent, parce qu'on veut
leur prendre tout ce qu'ils ont, parce
que tout ça, c'est un impérialisme qui
va assez mal avec l'affirmation de nos
dites valeurs, n'est-ce pas ? libéral,
social et cetera et cetera. Si vous
voulez, il y a des il y a des
contradictions tellement énormes qu'il y
a un moment où il va falloir vider
quelques abcès. Donc moi, je pense ça
ensuite
diplomatiquement, je je prétends que
l'équilibre de la guerre froide avait du
bon.
C'était un équilibre de la terre pour
tout le monde. Il avait du bon pour les
populations qui étaient de l'autre côté
du rideau de fer. Mais elle elle Oui,
mais on n'est pas là pour aller il
s'agit pas de sauver ces propusations.
Personne n'a jamais prétendu vouloir
sauver ces pays européens. Sauf dans le
discours bien sûr, mais enfin c'était
pas le sujet. Le sujet c'est toujours
une politique de conquête de divisé de
On ne fait que ça. On ne répé. Oui. Oui,
c'est ça. Plutôt la paix que la guerre
là. plutôt la guerre que la paix,
pardon.
Donc euh on a détruit en fait à partir
des années 90 quand je dis on encore une
fois c'est l'Occident et c'est les
États-Unis et les Européens qui ne sont
à l'époque et et encore aujourd'hui à
vrai dire que les vassaux en fait d'un
ordre
américain considérés comme puissant
entraînant permettant la la puissance et
l'influence des autres des petits de
nous l'avantage Pax Americana. Voilà la
Pax Americana. Donc cette Pax américana
euh elle est elle à partir du moment où
vous passez à l'unipolarité, à partir du
moment où vous ruinez cet objectif, vous
ruinez les accords sur l'équilibre
stratégique des forces en Europe, vous
vous ruinez tout, vous ruinez vous
ruinez Start, vous ruinez Salt, vous
ruinez tout ce qui a été fait pendant la
guerre froide. Donc il faut y expliquer
pour ceux qui ne savent pas start sur la
prolifération nucléaire le nombre de
missiles à courte portée, moyenne
portée, longue portée, ce qui faisait
qu'il y avait un équilibre de la
dissuasion.
Voilà, un équilibre de la terreur et que
chacun savait qu'il y avait que que le
conflit nucléaire était inconcevable
puisque ça arriverait à une une
destruction mutuelle assurée comme on
disait et que donc en conséquence non
seulement on conservait des canaux bien
sûr on se
faisait on s'infiltrait les uns les
autres on on était des concurrents, des
rivaux, des adversaires idéologiques
écon économique, militaire, tout ce
qu'on veut, mais on conservait des liens
de communication possible pour les cas
de crise, de dérapage ou
d'incompréhension et on faisait en sorte
de de préserver finalement si si c'est
tout le paradoxe de l'arme nucléaire et
de la dissuasion, c'est que c'est parce
que l'autre peut vous détruire qu'en
fait il ne le fait pas parce qu'il sait
que vous aussi vous pouvez faire la même
chose et que donc chacun reste reste sur
ses positions et les conflits étaient
très indirects. Donc à partir du moment
où on lance une offensive
occidentale de récupération
d'accaparement
de des anciens satellites soviétiques,
alors pour le bien des peuples, pour la
démocratie, pour tout ce qu'on veut,
mais enfin surtout pour les récupérer
dans le temps, les écoles pour les
petites filles. Voilà. Bien sûr, bien
sûr. Euh tout ça euh et bien forcément
tant que la Russie est faible, tant que
la Russie est
faible, elle n'en peut. Revenons à la
guerre et en plus elle avait ses
illusions sur sa possible intégration
même dans les mécanismes européens,
voire otanien et cetera. Il y a eu
beaucoup aussi
de, j'allais dire de rêves un peu fous
russe et même d'ailleurs de Vladimir
Poutine au moment où il est arrivé au
pouvoir les premières années. Premières
années. Revenons à la guerre froide
quelques minutes. Vous parliez de
conflits différés ou par proxy. J'allume
un conflit à gauche, tu m'allumes un
conflit à droite.
Ces petites taquineries avec le sang des
proxy. Est-ce que maintenant on est
revenu sur une dynamique de guerre
froide à je t'allume un conflit à
gauche, tu m'allumes un conflit à droite
et on monte, on monte, on monte la
mayonnaise. Moi, je pense qu'on est dans
une une nouvelle guerre froide mais
beaucoup plus dangereuse que la
précédente. Elle n'a jamais été aussi
chaude. Oui, c'est Oui, si on peut on
peut dire ça comme ça, mais en tout cas,
elle
est parce qu'il n'y a
pas il n'y a plus l'intelligence des des
situations en fait de notre côté.
Ça vient de quoi ? Ça vient d'une
intoxication de nos propres élites. Ça
ça vient du fait que on a plus notre
propre intégrité de parole stratégique,
d'analyse stratégique. Nous avons coulé
nos intérêts avec les intérêts des
Américains parce qu'on s'est rendu
compte que les Chinois et les Russes
allaient quoi qu'il en soit nous manger.
Ça vient de quoi ? Ça vient de la
formation de nos élites, l'intoxication
des prises de décision, le manque de
renseignement effectif de qualité. Alors
ça vient de quoi ? Alors vous vous mêlez
plusieurs choses. Je pense que
l'implication de ces trois paramètres
sont nécessaires pour la bonne prise de
décision. Oui, mais ça commence par
comment se
conçoit-on en tant qu'état, en tant que
pays, dans le jeu, dans le jeu
international. Or, que se passe-t-il
pour l'Europe déjà ? pour l'Europe parce
que l'Amérique elle a une visée
impériale
assumée depuis depuis toujours. Remaron
l'avait tellement souligné. Voilà, c'est
clair, c'est net. Sachant sachant on
change de méthode, on change de
personne. Bon enfin s'il y a bien
quelque chose qui est quand même assez
partagé et assez bipartisan aux
États-Unis, c'est quand même cette
volonté hégémonique. Et même aujourd'hui
Trump dans son dans dans ce qu'il peut
penser ou si ce qu' ce dont il peut
avoir envie n'a pas renoncé à cela.
C'est la même moi, c'est la même moi
épinière, c'est-à-dire continuer le le
la puissance impériale, c'est
l'exceptionalisme américain et la
manière dont il doit d'une façon ou
d'une autre s'en sortir. Et c'est pour
ça qu'il crée aussi des ennemis. Il il
les construit quand même. Enfin, quand
on voit ce qui se passe même avec la
Chine maintenant, je veux dire au plan
stratégique et au plan militaire, on
construit nos ennemis. L'Amérique
construit des ennemis. Bon, elle en a
besoin. C'est structurel, c'est comme ça
que marche aussi son économie et c'est
comme ça que marchait jusqu'à il y a
peu en fait, jusqu'à il y
a Moi, je pense que c'est avec l'Irak
que ça a commencé à décliner
complètement parce que là le le le le
double
discours est quand même est quand même a
commencé à fleurer de manière On avait à
l'époque Chiraqu Villepin et Guo. Non,
mais nous on s'en est sorti. Nous, on
s'est sorti enfin on n'est pas rentré
dans le bourbier iraakien de justesse
grâce à eux
effectivement. Mais les Américains à
partir de là, puis avec les printemps
arabes, puis avec la Syrie, puis avec la
Libye, puis avec et puis alors là
maintenant avec l'Ukraine, enfin je veux
dire, on est on est dans un
tel c'est un tel échec permanent. Enfin,
je veux dire en quoi on a apporté le
développement, la démocratie, la
prospérité, les droits de l'homme, à qui
? à qui, depuis quand, où moi je veux
qu'on m'explique. Ça me paraît
pas ça paraît pas flagrant. Moi quand
vous regardez l'état de la Syrie, l'état
de la Libye, l'état de
l'Irak, l'État de
l'Afghanistan, on parle de quoi ? Donc
on a on a on a trop menti quoi. Donc ça
ça com menti à qui ? Bah nos propres
peuples et aux populations qui ont pu
avoir envie de croire aussi à à ce à ce
phare occidental si vous voulez. Donc le
phare occidental c'est une loupiotte
aujourd'hui, faut comprendre. C'est
c'est un petit c'est une petite c'est
même pas une petite torche quoi. C'est
un petit un petit truc. Donc Trump il a
compris ça à mon avis. Ça il l'a
compris. Donc il faut recréer cette
crédibilité.
Donc je reviens parce que là vous me
faites digresser. C'est fait exprès. Je
reviens, je reviens, je
reviens. J'en étais
à la fin de la guerre froide,
l'effondrement de l'Union soique.
L'effondrement de l'Union soviétique, le
double élargissement
euh et euh
nous le fait que ça a marché tant que
tant que la Russie n'a rien pu faire.
Voilà. Et ça c'est le début des années
2000. Et dès le début des années 2000,
lentement le pays contre toute attente
et sous sous son nouveau pouvoir
commence à se restructurer et ça a été
très très long, très très long. Et donc
le discours change parce que l'équilibre
change. Et quand je dis que ce que ce
qu'a fait la Russie en Ukraine, ce qu' a
démontré la Russie en Ukraine, non
seulement elle nous l'a démontré à nous
qu'on que nos calculs étaient mauvais et
que qu'on s'était planté juste très
lourdement, hein, mais elle le montre au
reste du monde et ça, on n'en prend pas
la mesure non plus. Alors non, on en
était pas là, on en était à nos élites.
Pourquoi ça cloche ? Pourquoi on
comprend rien ? Pourquoi ? Ouai. Nos
astrologues de plateau télé. Ouais.
Ouais. Alors bon, un d'abord je pense
que effectivement il y a un problème de
formation euh de de Non, ça je reviens.
Ça y est, ça y est, je repars à mon fil.
Euh vous avez été entraîné à subir un
interrogatoire ou pas ?
Pourquoi vous me posez ce genre de
question ? Des carrés de sucre. Non, ça
va, ça va. Très bien. Non non simplement
non je manque pas de sucre ça ça va.
C'était pour que on puisse s'ajun Vous
connaissez pas la technique ? Non c'est
une technique qui est absolument
dramatique. Les carrés de sucre et pain
racis. Ceux qui sont familiers avec les
méthodes de torture vont vont comprendre
d'accord. Non, moi non, moi on m'a pas
entraîné à ça. Je suis un être
beaucoup trop beaucoup trop bon et doux
tout ça. On a on n pas chercher à
m'aguérir dans ce dans ce
domaineel.Endurcir.
Oui. Ah ben m'endurcir si. Mais j'ai
appris toute seule ça. Euh donc euh nos
élites nos élites alors nos élites elles
ont des problèmes propres mais le
problème le problème pour comprendre ce
qui se passe pour donner des ordres
sérieux à des services de renseignement
des des par exemple des directives
d'orientation de recherche des tout ça
pour il faut avoir une vision du monde
en
fonction j'allais dire d'une boussole
qui est une boussole nationale. Or,
qu'est-ce que
l'Europe qu'est-ce que l'Europe depuis
au
moins depuis Mastricht ?
La lente dérive vers un européisme
complètement fou qui en fait démonétise,
dévalorise les États mais nous renforce
face à d'autres blocs. Mais non, on
n'est pas on n'est pas fort parce que ça
ça c'est c'est ça c'est le plus petit
dénominateur commun des enfants en cours
de math je veux dire à 6 ans quoi. C'est
non c'est pas parce qu'on est 52 que on
est plus fort que quand on est trois.
C'est pas vrai. Il faut être fort
chacun. Or, tout le système européen est
fait pour détruire le sentiment
national, la compréhension de ce qui
s'appelle les intérêts nationaux.
Aujourd'hui, on a l'impression que c'est
un gros mot.
C'est comme la souveraineté, c'est pas
des gros mots tout ça. Donc l'Europe
serait beaucoup plus forte si elle était
une Europe des nations. Elle est de
moins en moins. Elle a abandonné des
pens entiers de sa souveraineté à une à
une superstructure qui ne comprend rien
à la géopolitique et qui s'imagine
justement que plus on est nombreux, plus
on fait bloc. Mais c'est pas vrai.
Regardez, même aujourd'hui, nous sommes
en
train depuis que Trump est arrivé au
pouvoir, ça y est, on a déclarer il faut
que nous allions vers l'autonomie
stratégique européenne, une douce
fadaise. Voilà, dont on n' pas le
premier rond, dont on sait très bien
qu'à la fin se terminera au mieux en
pilier européen de l'Alliance, toujours
sous contrôle américain, ça c'est sûr.
Bon, donc tout ça, on se paye de mots
nous-mêmes, déjà nous-mêmes, entre nous.
Bon et alors vis-à-vis des Américains
d'ailleurs, ils nous laissent faire
tellement ça leur
paraît pas très dangereux, on va dire en
terme de contrôle. Avantageux. Oui,
exactement. Ça finira par acheter des
armes parce qu'avant qu'on produise tout
ce qu'on raconte qu'on va produire va
quand même se passer une bonne
génération. Donc euh voilà, tout ça se
fait pas en 5 ans, même en 10 ans, même
en 15 ans. Revenons revenons à la genèse
d'une prospective, d'une anticipation,
d'un service de renseignement et de la
prise de décision politique. Et ben, il
faut il faut former des gens. Mais on
les alors avant de les former. Pourquoi
? On est dans le meilleur des cas borges
et dans le pire aveugle. On se fait
intoxiquer par qui ou on s'autointoxique
ou on n pas les capacités cognitives de
faire le bon diagnostic. trois les trois
mon général les trois mon général
les
trois donc colonel de réserve c'est ça
oui le lieutenant colonel ou colonel non
colonel les
trois
donc on est on ne on ne veut plus
apprendre on ne veut plus comprendre on
ne veut même plus
parler
avec j'allais dire l'adversaire et nous
en plus on considère que c'est un
ennemi.
On sait on sait même plus faire la
différence. L'ennemi, l'adversaire, le
concurrent, le rival, bon le partenaire,
le partenaire, voilà, le partenaire
éventuel, c'estd on a aussi des
partenaires qui sont des rivaux. Enfin,
je veux dire donc on vit on vit avec des
utopies, des illusions, des fantasmes y
compris européens. Et le résultat est
là. Si vous regardez l'Europe en ce
moment, elle est en train de se
fracturer au moment où on explique sur
tous les plateaux là, on a tout un tas
de gens qui nous exp On a jamais été
aussi fort, jamais été aussi uni, jamais
été aussi influent et puissant.
J'entendais encore ça ce matin. Mais on
se dit mais mais dans quel monde vivent
ces gens ? Est-ce qu' est-ce que
vraiment l'Europe est puissante,
influente, forte, unie ?
Enfin pour n'importe qui suivant un tout
petit peu l'actualité
internationale, c'est c'est l'exact
inverse. Donc comment est-ce que c'est
juste pour enfumer nos propres
populations, pour leur faire admettre
quoi ? C'est quoi l'idée à la fin ?
C'est de mourir tous ensemble. C'est le
joueur de Hamelin. On va tous à la
rivière et hop hop hop hop hop, on
glisse tous dans la rivière. Super. Et
on meurt tous. C'est bien. Bande de
petits rats. Génial. Euh, oui, c'est
c'est ça, c'est ça les mins. Euh non,
mais c'est c'est moi c'est les images
qui me viennent si vous voulez.
C'est-à-dire qu'est-ce qui raconte le
qu'est-ce qui tient le pipo là ?
Ah selon vous, bah pour moi ce sont ceux
qui veulent celui-là c'est l'Europe,
c'est nos nos élites consanguines, c'est
Alors déjà
c'est ce sont les réseaux néocons
américains et leur succès d'année et
leur produit d'ailleurs leur succès
d'année affidé.
Oui, enfin leur succès d'année, c'est
encore trop gentil. leur leur pas leurs
assettes leur enfin les gens qu'ils ont
mis au pouvoir peu ou prou depuis des
décennies depuis des décennies en fait
en Europe et qui promeent la même
politique. D'accord. Benz travailler
pour les services.
Il faut être pragmatique un peu. Est-ce
que on a des services capables
d'identifier ça des joueurs de pipo ou
des joueurs de X ou Y ? Mais non parce
que pour avoir notre propre intégrité
stratégique.
Mais non parce que pour ça il faut avoir
des hommes politiques qui la souhaitent
cette intégrité stratégique. Nous on est
euh on est tatamisé comment comme
comment comme comment c'est enfin on est
stockholmisé. On est stockmisé. Tatamisé
c'est la même chose mais c'est version
japonais.
C'est on est stockholmisé, c'est-à-dire
on est on considère qu'il est de notre
intérêt de jouer le jeu des néoccons
américains, d'attendre que Donald Trump
se plante au midterms et que le le le
démocrat les démocrates reprennent le
pouvoir au moins dans une des chambres
et que et qu'on en arrive vite à la fin
de ce deuxième mandat, n'est-ce pas ? et
qu'on puisse repartir comme en
12 avec nos voilà t tous les fantasmes
américain et c'est pour ça aussi qu'on
veut en Europe à toute force à mon avis
faire durer ce conflit pour attendre le
retour des démocrat bah oui parce que
plus ça dure plus ça dure hein mieux
c'est et puis on peut toujours espérer
n'est-ce pas Vladimir Poutine qui est
affublé une bonne quinzaine de cancer
maintenant au stade où nous en sommes
euh va mourir ou va connaître une fin
violente ou va être renversé. Si vous
voulez, on vit dans des on vit dans
c'est le pays de Oui. Oui, quoi. C'est
c'est nous vivons alors faisons une
expérience de pensée à la Oui. Ououi. H
donc Trump se fait taper sur les
marchés, on aide un petit peu les
crochepatttes à gauche à droite, il perd
les midmes, les démocrates reviennent.
Euh
euh dans 4 ans, il se fait dégager. Les
démocrates reviennent, les les Ukrain
sont encore
vivants, les les Russes n'ont pas encore
non plus n'ont pas pu avancer et on
repart comme en l'an 12. Ça nous mène à
quoi ? Mais ça nous mène à rien. C'est
bien ça le problème. Ça nous mène ça
nous mène à une perp un affaiblissement
progressif de l'Europe, à son
insignifiance stratégique, à son
incompréhension des dynamiques de
développement. qui ne nous attendent pas
sur le reste de la planète et notamment
sur notre fameux continent eurasiatique.
Nous, j'ai l'impression qu'on se
considère comme une petite planète.
L'Union européenne ne fait manifestement
pas partie de leur Asie. Elle comprend
rien. Une petite péninsule. Oui, c'est
ça. On est voilà, c'est ça. On est une
petite péninsule et toute notre énergie
est tendue vers un objectif hyper
intelligent qui est de mettre un rideau
de fer, de glace, d'acier, de tout ce
qu'on veut vis-à-vis du plus grand pays
du monde qui lui se projette
complètement dans l'autre sens. C'est
c'est ahurissant bêtises, je dire quand
même un peu béliqueux. Les Russes font
du renseignement chez nous, font de
l'infiltration, font de l'exfiltration
de données. Les Chinois font la même
chose à la chinoise. Mais les Américains
aussi c'est copains. Oui, mais alors
donc alors on n'existe pas. On je dire
les Chinois aussi ils font ça, les
Américains aussi font ça. Les
Britanniques aussi font ça et les
Français je l'espère bien le font aussi.
Nous on a Babar. Vous connaissez Babar ?
Non. C'est quoi Babar ? Dites-moi. C'est
un genre de Pasus mais avec des
rondzors. Une grande tr On l'a appelé
Bab. Non, c'est pas vrai. Si si. Ah bon
? Je peux pas le croire. Si si, c'estqu
Bon d'accord. C'est la classe quand
même. Oui, on l'aurait pu on aurait pu
l'appeler Bruno.
Euh oui aussi. Oui, c'est une autre
idée. Mais on pourrait l'appeler
Céleste. Non, je connais pas Baba. Non
non. Ben non, mais il y a plein de trucs
que je connais pas. Oui, Pegasus. Oui,
mais je connais pas. Je savais pas. Non,
mais vous plaisantez, vous plaisantez
pas.
jamais. Bon ben dites-nous alors
enseignez-moi c'est c'est une de nos
fiertés babar. Bon va on refera une
autre émission sur le renseignement sur
le hacking et ainsi de suite. Je pense
que notre communauté est très friante de
ce genre on a plein de copains à faire
venir en plus qui sont remontés comme
des baraques à frites. Revenons à notre
intégrité stratégique. Comment avoir une
pensée stratégique ? Comment avoir des
bonnes sondes ? Comment avoir des bonnes
sources ? Comment éviter de se faire
intoxiquer ? Comment éviter d'avoir
Pierre-pul Jackes nous raconter mon
émerveilles sur comment on va marcher
sur l'eau et comment on va sauver la
planète entière ? Comment on redevient
France ?
Quelle question ! Quelle question ?
Est-ce que c'est encore possible ?
C'est de plus en plus difficile. Est-ce
que vous modélisez parce qu'il
l'anilement ou la la la descente aux
enfers de la France ?
Ben, je l'observe. Je l'observe
évidemment et j'en suis observer comment
? Écoutez, c'est tout simple. la perte
des marchés, la perte des
positions, la perte de la compréhension,
le la noyade la noyade, j'allais dire
jubilatoire dans
le dans l'idéologie la plus pure,
l'incapacité à prendre en compte les
faits tout simplement. Et quand même, on
a un conflit là depuis 3 ans,
sous nos yeux, après je me fais l'avocat
du diable. On a nos leaders européens
qui vont se retrouver, qui font des
réunions, ils ont se serrent les coudes
et que ça fait des bises, des poignées
de main, que ça signe de la l'armée
européenne, qu'on envisage d'envoyer des
forces
d'interposition à gauche et à droite. On
n' été autant copain en Europe. Oui.
Alors, la Russie nous a soudé.
Oui, elle
nous Oui, elle nous soude mais elle nous
soude elle soude quoi ? Ouais, elle nous
doude bien. Ouais,
elle nous doude bien. Elle nous soude,
elle nous soude dans notre ignorance et
dans notre notre dogmatisme. C'est tout
ce qu'elle fait. Alors, elle nous elle
nous elle nous affaiblit en fait.
Pourquoi on n pas une conduite
introspective ? Parce qu'on y croit
encore. Parce que on a peut-être des
cartouches quand on entend Thierry
Breton dire attention à Trump, attention
on a des cartouches mais on les tire pas
mais on a des cartouches en guerre
économique, on va pouvoir répondre à vos
tarifs. Attention
non mais non mais là c'est là c'est le
c'est les très fonds de de du
du de la nulté si vous voulez. Très bien
Thierry, pourquoi il écoutez moi je je
vais pas faire de d'attaque à Dominem.
Je trouve que d'une manière générale, il
y a une indigence complète de la pensée,
de la capacité d'analyse. Tous ces gens
ils tournent en ils tournent en boucle.
Je sais pas de quoi ils se préoccupent,
mais manifestement pas de l'avenir de
notre pays. Euh nous il faut des
constructeurs, il faut des hommes
politiques, il faut des hommes d'état.
Mais où sont-ils ? Je n'en sais rien.
Alors on on si je devais prendre leur
défense h il vous juge comme
collaborationniste,
défeniste, tout ça bien sûr. Bien sûr,
bien sûr. Ben écoutez en tout cas jour
après jour la réalité c'est la défaite.
Voilà. Et la défaite elle est elle se
elle est le produit de leur décision pas
des miennes. Moi je prends aucune
décision. Moi, j'observe. Je suis euh,
j'allais dire dans ma grotte et et oui,
même pas. Et j'observe ce qui se passe.
Dans la grotte, on observe pas
grand-chose. Comment ? dans la grotte,
on n'observe pas grand-chose. Oui, mais
je sors, je sors, je regarde, je je mets
mes mes petits petites antennes. Euh
mais je veux dire euh c'est pas moi qui
fait la politique, c'est pas moi qui
prend les décisions. Enfin, il y a un
moment
où c'est on ne peut pas c'est c'est
j'allais dire ça me fait penser à Donald
Trump qui explique que cette guerre
alors dont il considère que ce n'est pas
la sienne mais enfin tout de même il a
aussi pendant son premier mandat aider
un certain nombre aider les Ukrainiens
il l'a fait bon et même avant de partir
il l'a fait bon bref les Javelins et
cetera quand il ça fonctionnait quand
les colonnes de char Russes sont arrivés
en Ukraine. Oui. Au tout début. Oui.
Sont fait massacrer. Oui. Mais parce que
Mais oui, mais là on revient à quelque
chose que vous avez aborder au tout
début, c'est que on fait comme si la
Russie voulait prendre toute
l'Ukraine. Donc notre raisonnement est
faux depuis le début si vous voulez.
Comment voulez-vous qu'on s'en sorte ?
On a des attendus qui sont motivés par
des par des raisons idéologiques ou du
renseignement ou des gens qui nous qui
nous expliquent que bah ils ont quand
même une industrie de guerre qui est
archi costaud. Ils produisent en un mois
ce qu'on produit. Ah non mais ça je suis
d'accord mais ça c'est autre chose. Là
je vous parle de des objectifs
militaires
territoriaux russes en Ukraine. C'est
quoi le leur objectif ? Ben, ils l'ont
dit euh, ils nous ont dit plein de trucs
aussi les Ils nous ont dit plein de
trucs. Ils l'ont dit sur tous les tons,
on n' pas besoin de prendre l'Ukraine.
Vous pouvez vous la garder. Je veux
dire, nous ce qu'on veut c'est reprendre
effectivement. Alors, au début, il y
avait deux oblastes mais comme on s'en
tête maintenant il y en a quatre. Ils
les ont collé dans la Fédération de
Russie et ceuxlà, ils ne les rendront
pas. Voilà. Donc il va falloir à un
moment donné manifestement les dernières
déclarations de Donald Trump, c'est que
il commence à comprendre qu'il y a des
des euh des enjeux territoriaux sur
lesquels euh ça n'est pas euh l'un de
ces l'un de ses émissaires au départ,
l'un de ses négociateurs au départ qui
est Scalog qui a raison mais plutôt
l'autre Steve Vitkov qui a une une autre
approche beaucoup plus pragmatique et
beaucoup plus réaliste à mon avis. Il y
a quand même des objectifs sur lesquels
il va falloir avancer un petit peu parce
que sinon ils n'arriveront à rien. Or
Trump lui il veut montrer qu'il a réussi
à mettre un terme à cette boucherie.
Voilà. Donc il fait des
déclarations, il essaie de enfin il ne
peut pas montrer trop clairement que
finalement ce que demandent les
Russes est
assez est assez basique à vrai dire,
c'est-à-dire pas d'Ukraine dans l'OTAN,
pas d'Ukraine dans
l'OTAN, des droits pour les populations
russophones, y compris celles qui sont
encore en zone sous contrôle ukrainien.
Euh les Oblastes, ils sont à Fédération
de Russie de toute façon dans la
constitution russe, dans
la réforme constitutionnelle aussi. Ah,
ça c'est encore autre chose. On peut en
parler mais dans la dans la constitution
russe révisée de de 2020, je crois, je
sais plus
2021, euh on ne cède pas un cimètre de
territoire russe. Donc c'est c'est mort
en fait. Alors mais il faut la place des
Ukrainiens. Ils ont Ah mais les
Ukrainiens, ils se sont fait avoir Non
mais les Ukrainiens, ils se sont fait
avoir par leur propre gouvernant. Par
leur propre gouvernant. Et là, il serait
qu'en même temps aussi euh qu'il se
passe quelque chose politiquement parce
que sinon ce qui d'après les sondages en
Ukraine, il est super populaire et que
c'est oui. Moi, je pense surtout que les
gens vivent dans une trouille, dans
une terreur à vrai dire parce que c'est
quand même plus vraiment un pays qui a
et c'est logique d'ailleurs parce que
c'est un pays en guerre qui a des modes
de
fonctionnement normaux hein, que ce soit
pour la presse, que ce soit pour les
partis, que ce soit pour tout, je veux
dire, ce qui est normal, ils sont en
guerre. Voilà, c'est ce que je viens de
dire. Donc mais le Zelinski de toute
façon lui il a interdit de parler avec
Russe. Il vient de dire il demande des
armes, il dit qu'il accepte le cesser le
feu, il passe sa vie à le violer, il
demande des armes expliqu je dire ah
mais les Russes ils vont continuer tant
c'est le problème de cette
négociation c'est qu'elle n'est pas
partie sur les le comment dirais-je sur
un
constat de l'état des forces militaires
véritables premièrement et de
l'état des exigences russes
euh basique qui ont pourtant été suriné
sur tous les tons depuis 3 ans. Comme on
ne veut pas reconnaître que la Russie
c'est ça l'enchaînement du mensonge et
de la et j'allais dire du déni, c'est
que si vous ne reconnaissez pas que la
Russie a
gagné, vous ne pouvez pas vous
vous continuer à dire que ah ben on ne
peut pas
capituler. On ne peut pas capituler
parce qu'en fait on n pas perdu. Donc en
fait, on va
continuer voilà et on va faire en sorte
de prouver à la Russie qu'elle n'a pas
gagné. Mais la Russie a gagné normal
pays asségé. Mais je dis pas que c'est
pas normal, ils ont perdu X génération,
ils sont fait Oui, enfin je rappelle que
Vladimir Zelinski s'est fait élier en
2019 sur un programme de paix avec la
Russie qu'il avait pas plutôt élu. Et
là, c'est une belle Psyops aussi
celle-là, hein. Vous avez annoncé qu'on
parlait des Psyops en voilà une belle.
Comment est-ce qu'on prend un individu
et qu'on en fait un homme politique et
qu'on le met au pouvoir et que après on
lui fait faire ce qu'on a envie qu'il
fasse ? Maintenant, il est prisonnier
des de ceux qui sont autour de lui aussi
et qui sont
pirmes internes, lui. Bon, sans parler
des gens qui le protègent, des gens qui
l'entourent, des gens qui le
conseillent. Ça vient d'où les sources
là et votre lecture ? Alors, quels sont
les noms de son entourage de qui sont
qui seraient plus béliqués que lui ?
Quels sont les Ah bah si vous regardez,
ne serait-ce que son chef d'étatmajor
Sirski, son chef du gour Boudanov sont
enfin je veux dire ils sont ils sont
tous c'est pas des timendres, c'est
c'est c'est ils sont terrifiants. Je
veux dire, il faut les les Russes
parlent de la dénasification. Bon, ça
c'est encore un autre sujet. Belle
psyops ou pas côté russe ? Je pense que
c'est une belle psyops côté russe. Oui.
Enfin, en tout cas, d'avoir repris le
terme
nazi euh même si enfin ça renvoie à
l'histoire hein, ça renvoie à ce
qu'avoir ukrainien pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale et cetera, à ce qu'il a
fait. Donc euh
Oui, enfin tout tout. Oui, tout. Mais
j'ai pas très très envie de parler de
tout ça, c'est c'est trop atroce. Euh
mais les Russes oui, bien sûr, mènent
des PSOPS aussi. Mais nous, enfin nous
les Américains, les Américains euh
d'abord avec Porochenko puis ensuite
évidemment avec Zelinski auquel quand
même pour lequel on a quand même créé
une série
télévisée. On a pris un acteur. On en a
fait un personnage dans une série
télévisée pendant près de 2 ans, je sais
plus, je sais plus combien de temps ça a
duré ce truc qui était un succès d'ord
qui était un grand succès serviteur du
peuple où il devenait finalement un
homme politique par civisme, par
patriotisme, par volonté de de de sauver
son pays et cetera et cetera. Paf,
là-dessus, hop, il se présente
évidemment euh en bonne en bonne
position. Il a été réclamé mais il a été
réclamé sur un programme de paix.
Mais quand vous entendez
Arestovic, je sais plus son prénom
Alexeil qui est un de ses conseillers
qui parle beaucoup surtout depuis 2 ans,
il a un peu quitté le enfin il dit
plutôt il dit plus qu'on ce que ce qu'a
envie d'entendre probablement
Zelinski. Il y a des il y a ça se trouve
d'ailleurs sur YouTube euh des
interviews
d'Arestovic qui expliquent que en gros
les Américains leur ont mis le marché en
main.
Vous allez, si vous voulez rentrer dans
le temps, vous faites la guerre. Il dit
même que ça va commencer en 2022, il
donne même la date, hein. Voilà. Donc
c'est bien. Et il dit "Ben en fait, on n
pas le choix. Si on veut rentrer dans
l'OTAN et être entre guillemets sauvé,
échapper véritablement à l'emprise, à
l'influence russe et cetera, revenir du
côté
européen, cette partie de l'Ukraine très
européenne et cetera. On doit faire la
guerre. On doit faire la guerre.
Bon, la Russine l'Ukraine n'était pas en
guerre là. Elle elle avait encore un
statut de neutralité. C'est à partir du
moment il s'était fait dépouiller la
Crimée. C'était compliqué quand même.
Oui, mais il menaaient une guerre dans
le Donbas eux-mêmes contre des
séparatistes. Contre des séparatistes.
Mais qui étaient des Ukrainiens ? Oui.
Non, mais bien sûr, il y avait les
Russes les aidaient et cetera. Bien sûr,
mais Poutine à ma connaissance n'a fait
entrer ses oblaces et a refusé toujours,
si je me souviens bien, les demandes des
séparatistes de Donet et de Louansk
pendant des années justement d'être
d'être récupéré dans la Fédération de
Russie entre guillemets. Ça c'est c'est
une vieille demande. Et ça ne s'est
passé que le 30 septembre
22, donc 6 mois après le même un peu
plus après le début de la guerre. Donc
tout ça c'est une histoire longue,
difficile qu'on n pas compris. Et
pourquoi on l'a pas compris ? Mais parce
qu'on ne veut pas la comprendre parce
que notre objectif est différent. Vous
savez, ça me rappelle les balcon des
intellectuels. On a des intellectuels en
France, on a des prospectivistes. Il
faut pas lever les sourcis comme ça.
Ouais.
On a des intellectuels, on a les
prospectivistes, on a service de
renseignement. Bon, ils sont ce qu'ils
sont mais on a quand même on avait quand
même des sondes. Vous savez, moi j'ai
vécu dans les années
90 le basculement de mon point de vue
avec le conflit
Yougoslave
euh d'une forme d'objectivité du travail
de renseignement
vers une subjectivité. c'est-à-dire une
réponse à des à des orientations déjà
politiques assez affichées parce que
l'avantage du renseignement, le propre
du renseignement, l'intérêt du
renseignement, c'est d'être une aide à
la décision politique. Il ne s'y
substitue pas mais il donne la matière,
il donne les éléments. Pour faire ça, il
faut être neutre, faut être capable de
se mettre à la tête dans la tête des des
Russes, dans la tête des uns, dans la
tête des autres et cetera. Il faut il
faut être antiidéologue. On fait monter
du renseignement brut. Alors la les les
tâes au-dessus, l'interprétation de ce
renseignement pour faire la petite
fifiche à Emmanuel.
Ah ben c'est où est-ce que ça cloche ?
C'est c'est les fiches c'est les Non
mais non mais entre l'analyste bon alors
déjà la source là le tri le machin
recoupement bon l'information. Après,
vous avez un analyste qui
analyse et qui a une idée produit une
interprétation. Produit une
interprétation. Mais après, qu'est-ce
qui se passe ? Il y a il faut que ça
monte, il faut que ça arrive jusqu'au
président de la République ou jusqu'au
ministre de la défense ou jusqu'au
ministre des affaires étrangères quand
ils sont aussi destinataires. Donc là,
il y a une déperdition
colossale à une colossale déperdition de
d'information, hein, voilà, et de
pertinence et de précision aussi.
Et plus ça va, plus les responsables qui
euh sont voilà, ils ouvrent les
parapluies, ils font attention, ils
veulent pas aller contre les
orientations politiques générales,
contre les déclarations qui ont été
faites. Donc on on recalibre, on
déforme, on déforme le renseignement.
Donc le vrai renseignement pur, j'allais
dire première main de vraiment de
première main qui est en fait assez bas
dans j'allais dire dans le
pipe, c'est pas celui forcément qu'elle
qu' a le qu' a le décideur politique.
Alors comment on fait pour réformer
cette percation ? Ah bah déjà faut un
président qui est en vie d'avoir les
vraies informations. Il faut faire quoi
? une conduite introspective sur nos il
faut faire quoi ? Les envoyer en
psychothérapie, faut faire Ah non mais
eux mais non mais vous savez, faut
engager des bad boys, il faut engager
des pas des gars qui font des grandes
écoles. Il faut faire quoi ?
Il faut déjà donner de bonnes
orientations qui ne sont pas politiques.
Or, les orientations qu'on donne à nos
services de recherche sont politiques.
sont politiques. Moi, j'ai eu la
l'occasion de de de m'occuper un peu de
coordination justement de de question de
renseignement et du plan national. Oui,
largement beaucoup plus que ça.
Euh enfin, je le suis plus hein, je suis
plus du tout. Je suis rien du tout
aujourd'hui. Je peux pas voir même
diffusion restreinte, je suis pas sûr.
Bah non, aujourd'hui voici par match.
C'est ça. Voilà. C'est ça. Euh donc mais
il fut un temps où j'étais très très
fortement habilité et
euh il faut donner des orientations si
vous ne donnez pas au service au début
de l'année des orientations. Par
exemple, si vous si vous ne dites pas à
si vous considérez que vos amis n'ont
pas besoin d'être espionnés, surveillés.
Surveillés, encadré. Oui, caressé.
On peut trouver tout ce qu'on veut. Euh
et ben vous ne saurez pas ce qu'ils
font. Voilà. Et après quand ils font euh
des opérations, des false flag, des
trucs, vous êtes "Ah bon ?" "Hon m'a pas
on m'a pas dit, mais j'étais là pourtant
mais on m'a pas dit." Voilà. Donc ça
commence comme ça. Il faut un plan
national de renseignement.
Je sais même pas si on a encore un plan
national de renseignement
aujourd'hui. Je n'en sais rien. Revenons
à la clé de
lecture. La clé de voûte. Ensuite, il
faut laisser la liberté aux
analystes et il faut il faut avoir des
politiques en haut du système d'état.
Pardonnez-moi, je vous interromps, mais
je termine. Il faut avoir des politiques
qui euh qui
acceptent et qui veulent qui en
demandent qui demandent vraiment
l'information pour se faire
véritablement une idée. C'est-à-dire
qu'ils doivent être libres même pendant
la guerre Yougoslave, pendant les
guerres Yougoslaves.
Euh en
Allemagne, chaque semaine, chaque
semaine, chaque semaine,
il y avait ce qu'on appellerait nous un
conseil de
défense et le chancelier Col à l'époque
faisait venir dans ce conseil de défense
qui est quand même le truc où il y a
juste les ministres, enfin chez nous, il
y a tout petit.
Il faisait venir l'indien. il enfin
l'indien le l'analyste faisait venir
l'analyste voulait il voulait entendre
son analyse à lui donc premier niveau
quoi, direct quasiment sorti du sorti du
du de l'anglaise quoi. Euh
il voilà il le souhaitait, il l'avait
exigé et ça s'est passé comme ça pendant
des années. Il y avait son N + 1 + 2 +
3. Oui oui bien sûr. Il y avait il y
avait les gens qui falaient, les ça
remontait très haut mais il y avait le
mec qui avait lui les sources qui
traitait, qui avait interprété et qui
avait une interprétation à proposer qui
n'était pas amoindri, qui n'était pas
euphémisé, qui voilà qui était qui était
vraiment efficace. après la décision
politique, c'est autre chose. C'est
autre chose. Vous pouvez avoir un
chancelier ou un président qui dit "Bon
d'accord, OK, j'ai compris, c'est ça qui
se passe, mais moi pour d'autres
raisons, je vais décider ça, autre chose
aux antipodes. Est-ce que vous savez
qu'est-ce qui quels sont nos services,
nos
organismes affiliés à l'État pour faire
nos prospectives ?
Mais vous voulez que je vous fasse une
description ? Je sais pas, on entend le
Caps, le centre d'analyse et de
prospective stratégique. Non, non, mais
ça c'est le K d'orsais, ça c'est Non,
non. Oui, enfin je sais pas, peut-être
que c'est bien. C'était c'était une
boîte à ID. C'était un s tank interne du
ministère des affaires étrangères.
Avant, ça s'appelait le CAP tout
simplement et puis après c'est devenu le
CAP. Cap géopolitique, c'est ça.
Voilà. Donc, il y a ça. Après, il y a la
DGIS. Bon, au ministère de la défense
qui est aussi mais qui s'est
terriblement civilianisé si vous voulez
où il y a beaucoup moins de militaire
qu'avant. Vous avez bien
bah oui et non. Oui et non. Comment vous
expliquez que oui et non parce que si
tout le monde sort science pot si vous
voulez s'il y a pas de bad boy. Non mais
c'est Non mais c'est vraiment c'est très
c'est on ne forme plus. Il y a pas
d'école réaliste. Moi, j'ai créé
Géopragma pour ça, mais malheureusement,
j'ai pas les moyens d'en d'en faire
quelque chose de
d'important. Euh, il y a l'école
réaliste en France, à part quelques voix
qui se permettent de temps en temps de
dire, de parler un peu, mais bon, qui
globalement vieillissent, on est on
n'est pas très nombreux. On est
euh euh Ouais. Enfin, on n pas très
nombreux expliquer que pour le reste le
directeur des renseignements militaires
conseillé Macron en disant "Vous
inquiétez pas, les Russes ils vont pas
frapper, il y a pas d'hôpital de
campagne, il y a pas les poches de
sang." Et bon 48 heures plus tard,
l'Ukraine se faisait enfoncer. Oui. Bah
d'ailleurs, il est plus là, il est parti
lui. Il a il a ou voilà, il a sauté, on
va dire ça. Est parti.
Bon euh c'est toujours plus compliqué
qu'on dit euh et qu'on le pense et qu'on
le dit et même ce qui se dit n'est pas
forcément ce qui s'est passé
véritablement. Euh mais
euh il peut y avoir des très des très
grosses erreurs
d'appréciation. Ça ça peut exister
aussi. Il y a des punitions.
Euh bah punition c'est c'est qu'on saute
quand on est très haut.
Euh sinon, il y a aussi des punitions
pour ceux qui font des études
intelligentes. Moi, je connais quelqu'un
qui en a fait une sur une des batailles
de cette guerre et qui a connu un
sort malheureux, professionnel, qui est
tombé d'un balcon. Non non non, il nous
n'exagérons rien. Mais je veux dire, on
lui a demandé de faire une étude, il l'a
faite mais comme les résultats de cette
étude ne correspondaient pas à
l'idéologie dominante du moment et ben
on le lui a on le lui a je rentrerai pas
dans les détails, on le lui a fait
payer. Mais payer comment ?
Professionnellement. On l' dit dans un
placard.
Voilà. Après lui avoir donné consigne de
faire une
étude sur une des grandes batailles de
cette
guerre. Voilà. Donc euh pour en tirer
des enseignements, revenons à la
perception de la population française
voire européenne avec nous nous on
appelle ça les les devins, les les
astrologues de plateau télé, les les
huiles, on les écoute, on regarde à peu
près l'ensemble du spectre télévisuel
francophone et international quand on a
aussi nos synthèses. Euh ils sont un peu
plantés, non ? Ah mais ça c'est un pour
moi ça c'est un mystère. Je ne sais pas
comment on peut arriver à ce niveau de
nullité. C'est une
syopse. Euh on peut le penser. On peut
le penser parce que c'est pas
possible de désinformer aussi
méthodiquement contre toutes les
évidences. Alors peut-être que vous avez
sois il désinforme pas. Il pousse vers
la victoire de l'Ukraine, il renforce,
il galvanis. Non non non non non non
non. les officiers et les officiers
généraux et même en dessous euh c'est
pas des journalistes hein. Voilà, ils
ont ils servent ils doivent servir le
pays qu'il soit à la retraite ou pas la
retraite. Ils doivent être conscients de
nos intérêts. Ils doivent avoir une
intégrité intellectuelle, morale, de
comportement et cetera qui fait que ça
n'est pas possible. Et ils sont et ils
ont en plus accès à des sources.
Bah oui, quand même, ils ont accès à des
sources auxquelles les d'autres n'ont
pas accès malgré tout, par les potes,
par les copains, par cci, par ça, même
sans être D'accord. Mais si là là que
leur source elles étaient aussi
pertinentes
qu' que du pain racis. Oui, mais
justement donc il y a a y a il y a il y
a il y a un comment dirais-je ? Il y a
une déconnexion totale entre ce qu'il
racontait et ce qu'il pouvait savoir.
Alors, c'est une déconnexion parce que
c'est des brêles parce qu'ils intoxiqu
parce que c'est des brêles. C'est des
brells qui intoxiquent ou s'ils sont sur
une idéologie, ils veulent pas voir la
réalité. Il il y a beaucoup d'idéologie.
Il y a beaucoup d'idéologie. Il y a
beaucoup de déniis. Il y a peut-être un
peu de goût de la de la popote, j'en
sais rien. Ça veut dire quoi goût de la
popote ? Je veux dire, bon, il y en a
certains qui forcément sont aussi payés
euh par les chaînes. Ouai. Alors, je
sais pas quand vous allez sur une chaîne
de télévision. Ah non, moi non. Non, moi
non. Mais quand vous êtes permanent,
oui, ça peut-être fait ça donne de la
crédibilité ensuite pour vendre des
livres. Mais peut-être,
mais quels que soient les motifs, je ne
peux pas croire. Moi, j'ai beaucoup de
mal à croire quand même parce que j'en
connais, je les connais presque tous des
bon. Il y en a quand même des bons.
Justement, je ne peux pas croire que
tous ces gens
euh ne se soit pas à un moment donné, à
certains moments de la
guerre, poser quelques questions mais
est-ce que je je suis pas je suis pas en
train de m'enfumer moi-même, de
peut-être de m'intoxiquer moi-même où
est-ce que ce que enfin c'est pas
possible. Vous avez un exemple, le coup
des laveselles. Ah non, mais alors là là
vous parlez de de du généralovlef
peut-être. Non, c'est pas Ursula qui qui
avait dit "Les russes piquent les
lava-vaisselles pour faire des
missiles." Si, mais ça c'est autre
chose. Non, mais celui-là, elle l'avait
elle l'avait elle l'avait pas trouvé
toute seule. On le lui avait dit. Alors,
qui le lui avait dit ? Je sais plus.
Enfin, vous vous savez, il y a plein de
il y a plein d'histoires, mais bon, on a
eu on a eu des exemples quand même
renversants sur LCI, sur
sur voilà et moi-même et moi-même qui ne
suis plus invitée évidemment depuis 3
ans. Pourquoi ? Parce que vous êtes
considéré comme prusse comme cremelimp
parce que vous avez oui mais on ne peut
mais bien sûr bien sûr. Oui oui je j'ai
je suis affublée de tous les mots de la
terre parce qu'en fait l'analyse n'a pas
coures ne travaillent pas déjà il y a
quand même des correspondants de
terrain. Oui, enfin oui, il y a c'est il
y a le pire et le meilleur dans les
correspondants de terrain hein et
notamment en Russie euh et depuis
longtemps mais on les laisse hein, on
les laisse et il sévissent et et il
beurent la tartine de tout le monde. Je
dirais il raconte n'importe quoi depuis
des années et ça fait partie
de voilà on sait qu'il raconte n'importe
quoi. C'est votre point de vue mais
c'est un point de vue. Mais c'est un
point de vue si vous voulez. Il y a un
moment où l'opinion, on peut dire qu'on
a tous des opinions, mais il y a un
moment quand même où les faits sont là,
sont têtu, les faits sont très têtus. Et
qui peut dire aujourd'hui sérieusement
que l'Ukraine a gagné ce conflit ? Déjà,
ils ont résisté. Même les Américains le
disent qu'elle l'a perdu, qu'elle l'a
voulu, qu'elle l'a perdu.
Enfin, c'est Trump et c'est pas que
Trump. C'est pas que Trump. Vous avez
vous avez son vice-président, vous avez
alors bon d'accord, on va m'expliquer
qu'ils sont tous complètement nuls. Bon
enfin à côté de ce qu'il y avait avant
si vous voulez à côté de à côté de Biden
et de sa clic, c'est des ass. Bon parce
que c'est tous des néocons complètement
néoconservateurs, complètement vicié,
vérolé, corrompu. Pour moi, c'est
vraiment vous avez des des sources de ça
? bah l'affaire Biden tout simplement au
plus haut niveau. Biden lui-même, son
fils euh qui euh s'est trouvé euh mise
en situation euh d'être d'être membre de
de d'un bord d'une société ukrainienne
euh dans laquelle il n'avait rien à
faire, pour laquelle il avait pas le
premier du début du commencement de d'un
cheveu de compétence euh payé
grassement. Comment ça c'est ? Bourisma.
Burisma. Ouais.
Euh enfin tout ça tout ça est là quoi.
Comment vous analysez le fait que Trump
serait un un actif
russe qui a été recruté ou intoxiqué ou
il y a très longtemps ? Bah ouais et que
il a été sauvé par des oligarques russes
que son empire qui se cassait la figure
c'est de du rouble qui a sauvé Trump et
que peut-être il se sentirait redevable.
Je sais pas moi, je regarde pas les
dessins animés. Je je fais plus. Je je
me suis arrêté à Calimero Babar. Candy.
Je me suis arrêté à Calimero Babar et
princesse Sarah. Non, même pas. Je suis
même pas allé jusque là. Non non. Oui
oui. Lî aux enfants. Voyez donc euh
c'est ça. Voilà. Est-ce que on se fait
on se fait un petit peu en fumé ? Vous
dites l'île aux enfants, c'est c'est le
petit ourson qui jette de la poudre de
Perlin pour Ah non, ça c'est bonne nuit
les petits. Bonne nuit les petits.
Connaissez pas vos classiques ? Non,
j'étais trop jeune. Oui, voilà, c'est
ça. Donc moi qui suis vieille euh je
connais mes petits. Vous avez quel âge ?
Non mais on demande pas ça à une femme.
À partir de 35 ans, c'est terminé. On
dit plus rien, même 30
ans. Je suis je suis pas tout à fait là
mais on peut dire que vous êtes bien
conservé. Alors ça va ça ? Ça j'en sais
rien. Si vous le pensez tant mieux.
Bonne nuit les petits. Bonne nuit les
petits Nicolas et Pimprenel. Donc là
est-ce qu'on a pas Nicolas et Pimproline
comment vous dites ? Nicolas et
Pimprenel. Ouais. Nicolas et Pimprenel
sont en Europe euh ont des lunettes
roses, sont en train de défoncer la
balance extérieure française, on a plus
de source d'approvisionnement pour
marcher, on a pas de matière première.
Euh ça devait devenir compliqué parce
qu'on s'est fait euh hauter bouter euh
d'Afrique euh dans les pires conditions.
Alors les Russes et les Chinois aussi
ont un petit peu euh même énormément euh
poussé le le mouvement ou euh que avec
l'Amérique du Sud, c'est un peu
compliqué. Euh et on se retrouve au
milieu du GAU et nous Pimponel et
Nicolas euh et petit
Emmanuel ça va donner courte histoire
pour les Européens et et plus
particulièrement pour la France. Si on
continue à à et que les Russes
continuent et qu'on continue à à se
mettre sur pardonnez-moi l'expression,
mais à se mettre sur la figure, on va où
? On va nulle part nous on va pas se
réindustrialiser
mais non menti. Mais oui. Non non non,
on est en plein suicide. On est en plein
suicide pour vous. On est en plein
suicide. L'Europe est en plein suicide.
Oui. He c'est un suicide. C'est pour nos
valeurs.
C'est un
suicide. C'est un suicide géopolitique.
C'est un suicide stratégique. C'est un
suicide économique évidemment.
Évidemment. Enfin, je dire mais c'est
l'idéologie, c'est nous sommes nous
c'est j'allais dire c'est pas bien fait
pour nous mais est-ce qu'on n'est pas en
train de se faire dépesser l'Europe pour
gagner du temps auprès des États-Unis
que les États-Unis gagnent du temps pour
pouvoir ensuite se farcir les Chinois ?
Je pense que les États-Unis et les
Chinois vont s'entendre pour nous pour
nous dépesser aimablement les uns et les
autres parce que
euh on est là en train de d'expliquer
qu'on
va comment dirais-je qu'on a tout un
arsenal de représaille. Alors dans
l'étonnard de la vertu. Oui,
naturellement. Ah bah surtout c'est très
important la vertu, les valeurs les
valeurs euh dont on se demande bien ce
qu'elles sont quand on voit à quoi nous
prêtons la main et notamment en Ukraine.
Mais bon euh donc oui, on a drappé dans
l'étendard de la vertu. Nous avons des
représailles mais on ne peut pas se
payer à la fois les États-Unis, la
Chine, la Russie euh et quoi bientôt
l'Iran, on fait quoi ? C'est quoi l'idée
?
On a rien compris à la marge du monde.
Commentort apporter la paix et la
démocratie ? Mais on ne les a jamais
apporté nulle part. Je veux
dire, on les a apporté où exactement la
paix et la démocratie depuis la fin de
la guerre froide
? Je sais pas, vous avez peut-être une
idée ou alors j'ai oublié quelque chose,
mais ça m'a pas frappé. Moi, je pense
pas qu'on soit là pour ça. Qu'est-ce que
c'est que cette cette espèce
d'ethnocentrisme ? occidental
complètement ça marche plus. Ça marchait
quand les autres n'étaient pas forts. Ça
ne marche plus. Maintenant, il y a
d'autres modèles. Ils sont tous
d'accord. Ils sont tous d'accord sur la
souveraineté des États. Ils sont tous
d'accord sur l'égalité des États. Ils
font des Est-ce qu'on est pas en train
d'an ? Ils font carton plein auprès des
pays d'Afrique et des pays d'Asie et
cetera sur le thème on va rétablir la
charte des Nations Unies et cetera. On
va le faire sous une autre forme s'il le
faut, mais en tout cas on va mettre en
œuvre et en musique cette multipolarité
et cetera. Ils jouent sur du velour.
Nous leur servons tous les jours sur un
plateau d'argent aux Chinois et aux
Russes
l'argumentaire l'argumentaire qui est
celui de leur influence présente et
future à cause du double standard qu'on
a servi pendant des années. Ben à cause
du double standard, à cause du fait que
les choses se voient, les choses se
savent désormais. Tout tout se. Est-ce
que nos élites
anticipent en regarder la Syrie, enfin
regarder la Syrie. Ben baché par Oui,
mais regardez ce qu'on a mis à la place.
On n pas des gens démocrates.
Donc on remet Daesche littéralement au
pouvoir. Littéralement. Il a une cravate
maintenant. Oui, il a une cravate, il y
a des costumes bien taillés et la barbe
aussi. Et il a changé de nom. D'accord.
Mais c'est quoi ce truc ? Enfin, je veux
dire, c'est tellement énorme. Comment
peut-on espérer convaincre ? Comment
peut-on
espérer rendre enthousiaste, donner
envie, rêver, faire rêver ? Bon, en tout
cas en tout cas tous ces pays qui
s'agrègent que ce soit autour des
brices, autour de l'organisation de
coopération de
Shanghï, de l'Union économique
asiatique, de toutes ces tout ça ça
avance pendant que nous on fait les
Marioles à essayer d'expliquer qu'on va
créer la défense européenne et
l'autonomie stratégique européenne. Mais
c'est vraiment mais on est on c'est de
la pignole.
C'est pas mon
vocabulaire. Mais ouais, un
peu. Non, mais si s'il faut le dire,
oui, faites rougir.
Ne rougissez pas. Revenons, revenons à
nos élites. Est-ce qu'ils anticipent pas
aussi euh la vengeance des pays qu'on a
mis en l'est pendant des années ? Est-ce
qu'ils anticipent pas le fait que les
Russes ils vont nous arracher toutes les
dents une par une histoire qu'on puisse
plus les mordre ? Ça va arranger les
États-Unis parce qu'ils vont pouvoir
nous vendre aussi du gaz très très cher.
Est-ce que nos élites qui campent aux
meilleures places dans les meilleures
cantines et dans les meilleurs salons
feutrés avec une moquette épaisse de 3
cm à s'échanger des cartes de visite
bien floqué avec d'une belle ancre, une
belle police et qu'on
fait euh vous viendrez prendre le petit
déjeuner dans mon S tank. Vous la
connaissez celle-là ?
Euh est-ce que nos élites sont pas en
train d'être en fuite en avant, en
cavalerie de peur que derrière les
peuples, les gouvernements change en
Europe ? demande des questions sur le
fait qu'on était sourd, aveugle, borgne,
cjat, boîteux ou appelez ça comme vous
voulez, qu'on a pas su faire et que ces
élites qui ont
été bien alimenté, bien nourris, bien
positionnés commence à avoir peur. Oui,
je pense qu'il y a une forme de peur.
C'est vrai l'attente
ou en dessous si vous voulez qui n'est
pas forcément d'ailleurs vécu comme tel
mais il est certain que si les peuples
se réveillaient un petit peu euh en plus
vous croyez au père Noël ? Non mais non,
je crois pas au Père Noël justement.
C'est pour ça que je dis si euh mais je
crains que enfin je pense que de toute
manière il y a le vrai sujet, c'est
qu'en Europe, il y a très peu finalement
de
gouvernants et ils sont en danger, y
compris
physique qui osent
défier en fait le magma informe
idéologique et la superstructure qui va
avec. euh
brelloise qui tient lieu de rêve
européens et d'alpha et d'oméga
européens. Il y a qui ? Il y a un
Slovaque, un
hongrois. Il y a quelques parties vouées
aux gémonies
naturellement en
Allemagne, Autriche, euh aux Pays-Bas,
bon mais avec des personnalités qui font
pas forcément envie non plus. mais qui
reprennent et là aussi elle joue sur du
velour et leur leur montée en puissance
nous nous en ce sont les parties de
gouvernement qui en sont les
artisans. Elle elle elle joue sur du
velour parce que en face il y a un
discours tellement peu ancré, tellement
peu ancré dans le réel en fait, ancré
dans les besoins des populations. Ancré
dans C'est quoi les besoins des
populations ? des 2200 calories par
jour, un peu de sécurité.
Non, c'est de sentir qu'on fait partie
d'un projet, mais pas c'est notre
projet, hein. Pas pas
celui-là. Euh c'est c'est Oui, oui. Non,
mais c'est pour ça. Non, mais j'étais
sûr que vous alliez me reprendre
là-dessus, donc je j'anticipe. Euh, ça
m'a échappé. Mais je pense que euh et
c'est aussi ce qui fait le succès en
Russie et c'est ce qui fait le succès
d'un urban en Hongrie et c'est ce qui
fait le succès de certains partis dit
populistes dans d'autres pays d'Europe,
c'est que il y a un discours de de
vérité sur cette notion d'intérêt
national, sur cette notion de
souveraineté, sur cette notion de
de protection, de sécurité et sur cette
question aussi de la cohérence et du
fait de en fait d'accepter de
revendiquer et d'aimer ses origines
historiques, culturell, religieuse. Tout
ça c'est pas des gros mots. C'est devenu
des gros mots dans l'Europe
d'aujourd'hui, dans cette Europe qui se
veut, je
reprends un terme de mon époque, de
l'île aux enfants. Un véritable gloui
boulga, c'est dire un truc ou voilà,
c'est Casimir ça. C'est Casimia qui
mangeait du glou boulka. C'est bien
quand même. Vous savez deux trois trucs.
C'est bien. Donc il mangeait une espèce
de pâtée informe là dans laquelle il y
avait tout et n'importe quoi. Il adorait
ça. Bon c'est ça l'Europe. C'est
l'Europe qu'on nous fait espèce de truc
qui produit effectivement de la règle du
de la contrainte.
Mais les vieux ils sont là. OK. On va
pas les il faut s'en occuper des vieux.
Donc euh bon euh mais il faut on voit
bien que nos pays manquent complètement
de cohérence et toute l'idéologie qui
nous est vendu dans ses formes les plus
extrémismes hein, je pense au wisme, je
pense à tout un tas de choses qui sont
c'est c'est délirant tout ça. C'est de
la destruction culturelle, c'est de la
destruction nationale. C'est peut-être
aussi une revanche des minorités. Ils
sont fait écraser pendant des années.
Ils sont fait derrière une idéologie.
C'est on a
créé non on
on LGBT c'était compliqué avant non du
temps de Casimir à votre époque c'était
compliqué de s'assumer non mais
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire si vous
voulez est-ce que s'assumer c'est
forcément au dépend des autres parce que
c'est c'est c'est c'est parce que les
minorités veulent devenir j'allais dire
centrales aussi c'est tout le problème.
On a inversé les processus mais tout ça
ça détruit un ordre social, ça détruit
une Pourquoi vous dites pas ça
reconstruit ? Non, ça reconstruit rien
du tout. Non, ça
déconstruit. C'est les hommes et les
femmes. Les hommes et les femmes. Et
surtout ça désoriente. Ça désoriente
complètement et ça isole à la fin. Parce
que si vous êtes si vous en êtes réduit
qu'à vos appartences minoritaires, bah
disons c'est bon courage. Dans ce
cas-là, vous en êtes réduit. En fait,
c'est antidémocratique pour moi tout ça.
Est-ce que vous avez pas un angle mort
de femme blanche de l'époque de Casimir
? Peut-être, sans doute, mais je
l'assume. Voilà, puisqueaujourd'hui, il
faut assumer ce qu'on est. Donc,
j'assume, j'assume très bien d'être une
femme blanche de l'époque de Casimir.
OK. Je n'aime pas le Glouy Bulga en
revanche. Et euh pour moi, parce que
vous avez été habitué à mieux.
Quel quel à votre avis, quels étaient
les réels penseurs ? C'était Raymon
Aaron, c'était qui d'autre
? Moi, je suis une littéraire, donc j'ai
lu tellement d'auteurs différents. Quand
j'ai commencé à faire des sciences
politiques, oui bien sûr, il y avait les
les querelles entre Sart et Aaron. Il y
avait il y avait Fouo, il y avait Deus,
il y avait les Vinas, il y
avait il y avait Nietz, il y avait
Chopenower, il y avait il y avait tout
un tas enfin moi je Arthur il était bon
hein. Non mais non mais on travaillait
plus quand même. On étudiait plus, on
travaillait plus, on réfléchissait plus,
on se distrait moins revenons à ma
question.
votre clé de voûte votre dans votre
prisme de lecture
qu'est-ce qui vous permet d'avoir une
lecture comme un laser sur ce qui se
passe la cohérence de toutes vos
analyses à gauche et à droite quelle est
cette clé de
voûte qu'est-ce qui est commun à tous
les sujets que vous pouvez filtrer,
analyser, collecter, absorber,
ingurgiter ? Je cherche des signalis pas
mal. C'est pas mal. C'est pas mal.
Euh vous êtes de l'époque de maître
Capello.
Oui. Puis Pierre des proches aussi. Pas
mal. C'est bien.
Euh vous avez trouvé ou je peux
continuer si je peux continuer ? Non.
Ben c'est quoi ? Ben c'est c'est ben la
cohérence. La cohérence c'est en fait le
refus. Non mais pour moi j'essaie d'
C'est pour ça que quand on me traite de
pro, je sais pas quoi, ça me paraît
tellement débile comme manière de faire
de comprendre.
Non, mais justement c'est d'essayer de
comprendre mais ça veut pas dire
justifier, ça ne veut pas
dire appuyer, ça ne veut pas dire moi
mon mon moi je je suis une analyse, j'ai
été élevée comme ça, j'ai été formée
comme ça. Donc je prends je je cherche
les informations, je cherche
l'arrièrefond, j'essaie de me mettre à
la place de l'autre toujours au maximum,
j'y arrive pas tout le
temps. Et j'essaie de faire ce que les
phénoménologues appelleraient de la
réduction phénoménologique, mais là ça
nous emmènerait loin. C'est-à-dire de
casser mes a priori. C'est exactement
l'inverse de tout ce qui est fait.
Casser vos a priori ou de penser contre
vous-même. Oui. Bah ça revient. Oui, on
peut le dire comme ça. Voilà. Tout à
fait. Mais en tout cas de ne pas juste
D'accord. Alors alors on va venir sur un
cas concret. Pourquoi Trump prend le
veut prendre le Croenland ?
votre clé de voûte pour analyser quoi ?
Alors, je pense déjà euh d'abord je sais
pas si ça va marcher. Premièrement, je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup La question
c'est pourquoi ?
Mais je suis pas sûre qu'il le fassent
déjà. Pourquoi ? Pourquoi ? Mais
peut-être probablement pour embêter les
Européens en grande partie. Alors,
pourquoi vous arrivez à cette constat ?
et ben parce que il est il est dans
un s'il
veut chifter ses dispositifs d'abord
s'il veut remettre sa croissance à
l'intérieur du pays recréer pouvoir bon
tout tout ce qui se passe là avec les
tarifs doués clé de c'est l'énergie
clé de voû c'est l'énergie clé de voû
c'est la fiscalité oui enfin c'est c'est
tout ce qui va lui permettre de
retrouver des marges de souveraineté
intérieur par rapport à un conflit qui
lui paraît le plus structurel. Là, c'est
très simple pour lui, le plus
systémique. L'énergie est très chère en
Europe. Il aspire tous nos talents, il
facilite la carte verte pour les talents
et donc clé de voûte énergie, on est
d'accord.
Oui, enfin c'est une clé de vous, c'est
un moyen. Oui. Oui, c'est un moyen.
C'est pas forcément une clé de voûte,
c'est un moyen. Son
objectif, c'est de recréer la son
objectif ultime, c'est de recréer la
puissance et de et de redonner des
fondations possibles à une forme de
nouvelle hégémonie américaine. À mon
avis, il se plante Groenland. Oui. Bah
Groen, qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je
vous dise sur le Groenland ? Je sais
pas, les pingouins sont jolis, ça se
passe bien. Non mais le Groenland, le
Groenland c'est une c'est une mine
énergétique justement. Donc c'est aussi
une position stratégique pour contrôler
les routes. Alors il y a la Tout à fait.
Il y a la route du nord, il y a Tout à
fait, tout à fait. Bien sûr, c'est Bien
sûr il est il cherche à il cherche à à
limiter la marge de manœuvre. la marge
de oui de manœuvre euh de ses
concurrents possibles. Donc il cherche à
se mettre en position. Voilà, c'est
tout. Si on prend le planisphère, ça
serait bien d'ailleurs d'avoir un
planisphère pour ce genre de
d'émission.
Euh il laissait ça. Mais ce qu'il
laissait vouz quoi ? Un mercat, vous
voulez quoi ? Ouais. Fantom Mercator,
non, c'est trop ancien. Il nous faut un
bon
planisphère bien clair, bien net avec
des petits où on peut faire des zooms
sur des zones. Ça c'est un truc que
j'aimerais bien avoir. Donc
euh donc Trump ce qu'il veut c'est la
souveraineté et il a compris aussi.
C'est recréé en fait, c'est recréé les
moyens d'une hégémonie. Comment vous
analysez les tarif ? Comment vous
analysez les tarifs douigners de Trump ?
Il s'est levé un matin, il a dit "Vas-y,
on va mettre 125 % aux Chinois, on va
mettre 20 % aux Européens, on va leur
montrer qui c'est le patron". Bon, il
s'est un petit peu rétracté sur certains
produits. Il sait pas. Ouais, il sait
Alors déjà, il a
mis hors hors
tarif qui ? La Russie et la
Biélorussie. C'est intéressant ça. Bah,
Uranium.
Oui. Non mais il l'a fait et quand on
sait que les émissaires et que Vitkov
notamment passe sa vie entre
Moscou et enfin bon, il va il va un peu
partout, c'est assez
intéressant parce que ils sont en train
en fait de dent américains et russes un
certain nombre de d'accords économiques
et d'accords
énergétiques qui seront à mon avis des
sous-bassements importants pour un
éventuel apaisement en Ukraine.
S'il y arrive, s'il y arrive décoller la
Russie de la Chine. Oui. Alors ça, bon
ça, je pense que ça va être très
compliqué. Oui. Bon courage. Je pense
que là c'est là c'est c'est le problème
de Trump, c'est qu'il veut tout en même
temps. C'est dire il veut que la Russie
s'arrête, il veut que la
Chine décolle de la
Russie, il veut en même temps que le
Moyen-Orient, ça se passe aussi comme il
le souhaite avec l'Iran. et là il a
besoin des Russes mais en même temps, il
les gêne en perdant du temps sur
l'Ukraine. Enfin bref, il essaie de tout
obtenir en même temps. C'est là qu'il
est à mon avis un peu maladroit. Euh
mais après les tarifs euh bah je pense
que oui, il y a une volonté de de faire
de relocaliser un certain nombre de
productions aux États-Unis au risque
d'une inflation au départ de faire en
sorte de revaloriser et là pour
l'instant ça s'est pas passé tout à fait
comme il le voulait les bons du trésor
américain. Bon là qu'il essaie de faire
refinancer son déficit intérieur. Ben
oui, mais oui parce que l'Amérique vit
sur la dette elle est nous elle est
colossale mais eux c'est je sais plus
c'est un triard un triard 2 je sais plus
enfin c'est combien de zéos 1 milliard
pardon il y a combien de zéos en 1
milliard alors 1 million 1 milliard bah
il y en a neuf
pourquoi il a un qu Non parce que c'est
c'est un running gag qu'on a lancé et
maintenant on pose la question c'est un
running gag de la communauté je prends 5
points à chaque fois que je fais le gag
euh je vous pose la question sur la
Chine. La Chine veut quoi ? La Chine
veut reprendre sa son hégémonie
mondiale. La Chine la Chine a fait la
route de la soie. Pourquoi ? À cause du
collier de perle. La Chine anticipe quoi
quand
elle sert la vis des terres rares à
l'exportation quand elle n'exporte plus
?
Bah la Chine elle réagit et vous avez vu
que que la Chine est rancunière.
La Chine a la mémoire
longue. Alors après, il y a tout ce
discours sur le thème, elle a été
tellement brimée, tellement contrainte,
tellement pillée elle-même pendant des
siècles que maintenant elle se
vengerait. Je pense pour moi, c'est pas
une ligne de lecture très enfin c'est
facile. Euh la Chine est une puissance
commerçante. La Chine est une puissance
qui a besoin de se
déployer et qui va le faire et qui va le
faire. Et les routes de la soie vise à
cela évidemment. Afrique aussi hein.
Elle s'est déployée en Afrique. Oui,
elle se déploie partout mais bien sûr
c'est une puissance connaissante mais ce
n'est pas forcément une puissance une
puissance qui a un modèle de puissance
comparable à celui des États-Unis. Je
pense même que c'est pas du tout le cas.
C'est la la projection militaire n'est
pas une fin en soi alors que la
l'impérialisme américain se nourrit
d'une capacité de projection militaire.
Et et c'est bien le problème qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui, c'est que il faut qu'il
faut qu'il rattrapent le rythme des
Chinois qui quand même produisent très
très très vite. Question internet.
Est-ce que madame Galacteros a reçu
quelconque financement étranger pour ses
prises de position ? Jamais. Vous avez
des preuves de ça ? Ben, prouvez-moi le
contraire. Jamais de toute de toute ma
vie. Est-ce que Est-ce que les services
ont fait votre pédigré, vos comptes en
banque, vous êtes sur écoute ? Est-ce
que ça ? J'en sais rien. Probablement.
Probablement. Mais ils font leur
travail. Oui. Enfin, moi ça me dérange
pas. Sur écoute les autres.
Est-ce qu'il ça c'est un autre sujet. Ça
c'est un bon sujet. C'est un très bon
sujet parce que moi je veux bien qu'on
me trouve tous les tous les défauts de
la terre. Pourquoi on vous trouve tous
les défauts de la terre ? Mais parce que
je dis la vérité. Parce que je dis je
dis je dis des choses qu'on a pas envie
d'entendre. Parce que je mets les choses
en perspective. parce que j'explique que
nous avons une mauvaise politique
étrangère, voire même pas de politique
étrangère du tout parce que je souhaite
la reconstruire parce que je ça revient
souvent ça qu'on vous accuse d'être un
assette étranger, d'être dans la main de
X Y de Popof 1, de Sergeille,
qu'est-ce que vous voulez ? C'est
c'estes tous ces gens euh déjà porté
plein de proffirmation.
Euh oui, je l'ai
fait. Oui, je sais même plus contre qui
contre quel un type de France interne.
Je me souviens plus fois. Je me souviens
plus. Il y a des il y a 5 6 ans mais moi
ça me fatigue tout ça. C'est c'est
tellement pathétique, c'est tellement
indigeent. C'est donc c'est vrai que je
réagis peu de temps en temps. Je je
balance un petit scut sur sur X parce
que ça me ça me fatigue trop. Vous avez
regardé la la Commission des affaires
étrangères sur les ingérences
extérieures ? Ah oui. Non mais j'ai des
j'ai des ennemis puissants et
probablement qui auraient certainement
des
allégances tout à fait répréhensibles,
mais que l'on ne trouve manifestement
pas répréhensible. Oui. Alors, il y a eu
cette fameuse
commission sur les ingérences étrangères
de l'Assemblée
nationale et là il y avait il y avait le
sueur Nicolas Tenzer qui comme ça, je
sais pas je sais pas quels sont ses ses
sources, enfin c'est c'est de la pure
diffamation. Oui, c'est même de la
calomnie.
Euh parce que c'est pire euh à à
expliquer bien la calomnie vole de
bouche en bouche. Certes, enfin à
expliquer que Géopragma, donc le petit S
tank, la petite association que je
dirige euh qui n'a pas une activité
débordante d'ailleurs euh par rapport à
Desque Russie qui est son qui est son
gagne pain peut-être probablement, enfin
l'un de ces gagnepins, je n'en sais
rien. était travaillait pour des
intérêts tangés. Donc voilà. Donc ça
c'est ça c'est typique des condamn des
des des
déclarations qui qui sont faites comme
ça. Voilà, il il s'autorise le fait de
le faire. Alors comment peut-il
s'autoriser le fait de le faire ? Alors
là, j'ai là, j'ai répliqué quand même.
J'ai écrit, j'ai demandé à être moi-même
auditionné, j'ai demandé à pouvoir
répondre, à pouvoir mettre dans la
gazette de l'Assemblée nationale un
enfin une réponse quand même à une
attaque comme ça. Il attaquait aussi
d'ailleurs d'autres he, il attaquait, il
attaquait je sais plus, on était trois
ou quatre, il attaquait le centre fran
français de recherche sur l'enseignement
d'Éric des Nesset. Enfin
bon, donc euh enfin comme par hasard,
voilà, Éric des Nessé, c'est aussi un
professionnel sérieux que je connais
fort bien, que j'apprécie, qui est
quelqu'un de très de très professionnel,
mais voilà, tous les gens qui ont en
fait une en fait une
crédibilité par leur passé, par ce
qu'ils ont fait ou par ce qu'ils font et
cetera, cela faut les dzinguer. Voilà.
Donc ces gens-là qui les payent en fait.
D'ailleurs, c'est ce que j'avais dit sur
un sur un tweet, je crois bien. J'avais
demandé si il serait possible de
connaître l'origine des revenus de cet
individu. Et il n'est pas il n'est pas
le seul. Question, je relie la question
parce que ça ça travaille en meut, hein.
Est-ce que tous ces gens-là tous ces
gens-là agissent en meut ? Les livres
sterling, ça brille. Euh est-ce que euh
je je relie la question euh et on
rétorquera le rouble aussi mais c'est ça
me fait rigoler. Oui. Non mais moi euh
est-ce que madame Galacterous a reçu
quelconque financement étranger ? Alors
je vais je vais compléter la question.
J'ai dit non. D'accord. Euh euh est-ce
que vous avez voyagé ? Est-ce qu'on vous
a payé des voitures, des bagousses, des
chambres d'hôtel, des voyages à Cuba,
des cigares, des caisses de pinard ?
Vous avez été invité dans des colloques
en Lituanie, en Estonie ? Est-ce que
vous allez à un colloc dans les pays
Baltes au au
25 euh je crois que c'est juin un truc
comme ça. Vous allez dans des des choses
comme ça ? Est-ce que vous avez été
invité par l'Iran, la Russie, la Corée
du Nord dans des palces lors de
colloque. Est-ce que vous avez eu des
avantages en nature pour compléter la
question ? Aucun aucun strictement.
Enfin pour qu'il me prendon. Non non non
mais j'ai pas besoin de ça. Je ne je ne
Est-ce que est-ce queon a déjà essayé je
ne suis pas mais une puissance
béniqueuse a essayé de vous tamponner ?
Vous avez été approché par Pierre Paul
Jacques Sergil Mola machin ou pas ? Mais
on est on rencontre enfin je je fais pas
rencontrer Sergier Lavrov. Je
d'affure de frais ou des ou du tricot
hein. Donc les relations international
en fait ça se fait mieux quand on
rencontre les gens. C'est marrant mais
voilà pour essayer de comprendre, de
connaître, d'écouter, faut quand même à
un moment donné sortir de son petit trou
et aller au contact de voilà des autres.
En fait, c'est c'est un peu juste la
base du métier. Bon, donc le sujet n'est
pas de rencontrer des gens de puissance
belliqueuse. Alors après, étant en
guerre, n'étant pas en guerre, je sais
pas, il paraît que non, mais oui, mais
non, on sait pas. Bon, donc euh bien
sûr, j'ai eu l'occasion d'aller en
Russie d'aller combien de fois sur vos
propres donniers ou pas ?
Alors, vous avez payé l'avion et ils ont
payé l'hôtel ou est-ce que c'était prêt
en charge à 100 % ? Euh, comment ça se
passe ? Ça dépend pour quoi faire. Euh
quand
on quand j'allais pour participer à des
coloques sur euh les questions de
migration, c'est pour une université
russe. Quelle légitimité vous avez pour
parler de migration ?
Bah, quelle légitimité j'ai ? parce que
j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur Vous avez
été approché pour partir là-bas, vous
avez reçu une lettre, il y a quelqu'un
qui vous a toppé la main. Comment ça se
passe ? Euh, j'ai une proposition. Par
qui ? Bah, par
l'université en l'espèce, l'ancienne
l'université. Vous avez fait le pédigré
du mec qui vous a envoyé le mail. Est-ce
que vous avez prévu les services de
renseignement français avant de partir
là-bas ?
Non mais non, c'est con quand même. Vous
êtes vous aviez été accrédité, il
fallait quand même prévenir les service.
Non non non, attendez attendez d'abord
je sais pas pourquoi vous me posez
toutes ces questions à la noix. Euh
premièrement, je vois pas ce qui vous
autorise à le faire à moins que vous
soyez vous-même travailler pour un
service.
Deuxièmement, je ne travaille plus pour
le service français ou un service de
puissance béliqueuse ? Non mais soyons
sérieux, c'est c'est des choses
sérieuses. Moi je je voilà. Donc euh
j'ai fait partie d'un groupe d'experts.
Il y avait des Italiens, des Allemands,
des Belges, des Suédois, des Danois, des
bon et des Français. Voilà, dans une
université qui est une des plus connues
probablement en Russie qui est la
Roudine, donc le l'ancienne université
Patrice Lumoubal, l'université pour
l'amitié des peuples qui a énormément de
d'étudiants étrangers et donc il y a des
séminaires qui se tenaient mais c'était
il y a longtemps il y a 10 ans déjà il y
a
2015 vous on vous a proposé des choses
là-bas des chambres garnies mais rien du
tout mais mais enfin mais ça va pas non
Mais vous me prenez pour qui ? Non non
moi ça va, je ne suis pas je ne suis pas
vénale
et et on m'achète pas et alors
certainement pas avec des champs garni
ou je ne sais quoi. Voilà avec rien en
fait. J'ai besoin de rien. Il a même pas
de chocolat. Non mer même pas.
Est-ce qu'il y a la même chose du côté
américain ? Est-ce que ils vous sont
fond par la fondation France
Amérique intégré initiative ou des
choses comme ça ? Alors ça oui, ça c'est
ça c'est un endroit je crois très
intéressant digne d'intérêt en tout à
fait et de toute manière les réseaux
pour nos services pour bah ce serait
bien oui parce que ça nous permettrait
quand même d'identifier tous les agents
infiltrés qui travaillent en fait pour
les États-Unis ou la Grande-Bretagne.
C'est quand même intéressant. On est on
est français quoi. On n'est pas donc la
Russie est peut-être hostile et
l'Angleterre nous paraît moins. Ou vous
avez suivi en
cus les sous-marins ? Ah ou un tout
petit peu. Oui. Non mais c'est pas de ça
que je voulais vous parler.
Euh j'ai j'ai fait l'objet moi d'un j'ai
j'ai fait un très grand et magnifique
voyage aux
États-Unis pendant plus d'un mois
pendant que j'étais en fonction.
Donc payé par qui ? Bah par les
États-Unis. Et qui aux États-Unis ? Bah
le département
d'État.
Euh donc c'est des ça s'appelle ça
s'appelait pas si ça s'appelait
l'International Visitors Program. Donc
il cible des gens dans tous les pays du
monde et c'est toute la toute l'année en
permanence et cetera selon leur
fonction, selon
leur leur potentiel où ils seront dans
10 ans. Bon et on leur fait découvrir
les États-Unis et l'appareil
euh j'allais dire ouais le complexe
militarau industriel américain et
gouvernemental aussi et intellectuel
aussi. Il y avait du chocolat. C'est
tout à fait
passionnant. Ça c'est fait. Ça c'est
fait. C'est autre chose que d'aller de
jours dans un séminaire sur les
migration à l'université pour l'amitié
des peuples. C'est grand grand genre. La
véchelé. La véchelé. Vous vous ça veut
dire quoi la véchelé ?
L'argabanu. Voilà. Vous avez combien ça
coûtait ?
Mais j'ai demandé l'autorisation de mon
secrétaire général de la défense
nationale. Évidemment, est-ce que vous
étiez en service ? J'étais en service.
Vous avez rempli quel serfa ?
C'était il y a tellement longtemps, je
sais plus, il y a 30
ans. Donc donc voyez donc ça ça a été
très intéressant pour moi et très
instructif. Il y avait des gens des
services de renseignement français qui
étaient sur place. Est-ce que les
services français vous ont demandé de
collecter les noms des gens qui étaient
sur place ? Non. Nous étions une bonne
quinzaine, il y avait toute l'Europe,
hein, toute l'Europe, y compris les
futurs parce que c'était c'était il y a
des thèmes et moi j'avais choisi un
thème sur l'extension de l'Alliance
atlantique. Donc c'était très
intéressant. Il y avait certains des
pays qui allaient bientôt entrer,
n'est-ce pas
? Non non, c'est c'était tout à fait
passionnant et c'était très intéressant
de voir comment on on cible et on et on
convainc et on séduit en fait. Moi ça
m'a moi je moi avant de me séduire si
vous voulez sur avec une tablette de
chocolat. Ouais, même avec une tablette
de chocolat. Même avec deux tablettes de
chocolat. Donc
euh moi je je suis très voilà euh
j'écoute, je très bien mais enfin je
n'en pense pas moi. Donc euh je je reste
ce que je suis. Euh mais c'était très
intéressant, c'était hyper
professionnel, hyper professionnel,
hyper organisé, très intéressant. On
devrait faire la même chose en France.
Pourquoi on le fait ? On doit le faire.
On le fait. Il y a eu une tentative, je
sais plus comment ça s'appelait, mais il
y a au moins 15 ans. Je sais pas si ça
existe encore, mais on faisait ça mais à
notre tout petit niveau avec des toutes
petites quantités de personnes tandis
que ils arrosent mais très large sur la
planète toute l'année sur plein de
thèmes qui intéressent naturellement les
gens qui sont ciblés.
Question internet qu'on va attraper la
première. Que pens-t-elle de Medvedef
qui appelle les États-Baltes nos
provinces ? Je pense que Medvedef a un
rôle comme d'autres d'ailleurs dans
l'entourage de Poutine de
haut-parleur si vous voulez. C'est un
orchestre quoi. Donc vous avez le
président, vous avez Lavrov, vous avez
Zachaova, vous avez POV. Bon et puis en
dessous il y a il y a d'autres il y a
d'autres instruments de musique qui sont
chargés de jouer plus ou moins
fort et d'être plus ou moins brutaux et
d'être plus ou moins inquiétant et de
voilà donc chacun a son
registre. Voilà. Question internet.
Est-ce un droit ou devoir ? C'est de la
provocation quoi plutôt. Comment c'est
de la provocation ? La pure provocation.
C'est de la fait. C'est non c'est de la
provocation. C'est une façon de
galvaniser sa population interne aussi.
Aussi surtout aussi je sais pas surtout
je sais pas mais oui bien sûr de toute
façon tout ce qui est fait ça aussi
c'est comme Bruno Lemer qui dit qu'il va
mettre l'économie russe à genou. Oui
c'est pour nous galvaniser chouette. Bah
oui on s'est tous mis derrière en été.
Bah oui mais c'est génial. Ce qui est
vrai c'est que les les toutes les prises
de position de tous les dirigeants, que
ce soit Trump que ce soit c'est un peu
la cour d'école.
Non, mais il faut on sous-estime
toujours euh l'intérêt électoraliste,
l'intérêt politique interne euh de ces
déclarations. On les
prend on les prend toujours pleine phase
en se dire "Ah, il a dit ça" mais il a
dit ça aussi surtout pour son électorat.
Voilà. Et Trump est un très bon exemple
de ça. Mais Poutine aussi. Poutine
aussi. Emmanuel Macron aussi. Emmanuel
Macron aussi bien sûr.
Question internet. Est-ce un droit ou un
devoir pour un militaire de dire non
face à un ordre illégitime ? Alors la
personne doit faire peut-être référence
à la théorie des bayonnettes
intelligentes. Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Vous allez m'apprendre quelque chose ?
Non, je vais vous rien vous apprendre ce
soir. Donc je pense que oui, un ordre
illégitime, un militaire peut dire non.
ou du moins poser poser sa bayonnette.
Euh ben j'ai été professeur à l'école de
guerre pendant quelques années. Ouais.
Alors si c'était à l'époque de Casimir,
ça s'appelait pas l'école de guerre, ça
s'appelait collège interarmé de défense.
Oui. Non. Moi moi ça s'appelait de
nouveau l'école de guerre. Alors c'était
plus à l'école c'était plus l'époque de
Non, c'était plus d'ailleurs je ne
regardais plus Casimir depuis déjà
quelques temps. J'ai arrêté j'ai arrêté
vers mes 20 ans. Casim c'est vrai.
J'étais tard. Ah oui, c'était très dur.
C'était très très dur.
Euh donc euh quand j'étais j'avais des
enseignements optionnels dont je
m'occupais à l'école de guerre ou au CID
aussi effectivement avant
euh et j'avais un séminaire qui
s'appelait éthique morale et conflit et
c'est exactement ce
sujet, c'est-à-dire le
conflit à la fois de loyauté, de
d'injonction contradictoire, le conflit
intérieur fort qui peut exister à
certains moments en
situation entre les ordres, la
mission et l'éthique propre, l'éthique
du soldat et sa conviction et qui peut
le conduire à faire des choix qui sont,
j'allais dire ni bons ni mauvais qui qui
seront peut-être mauvais pour la mission
mais bon pour pour le fait qu'il
reste entier, intègre lui-même garde son
intégrité morale éviter les les crimes
de guerre.
C'est c'est un exemple un bon exemple.
Euh ou l'inverse, voilà. Ou
alors il va faire ce qu'on lui demande
et il en souvrira beaucoup.
Les crimes de
guerre, on voit les Russes bombarder à
Touva des zones
civiles. On voit les Ukrainiens, on voit
les zones les Russes bombarder à Touva
des zones civiles. Vous parlez de soumis
? C'est intéressant. Je parle pas de
soumis soumis, ça a pas été encore
expliqué. Il y avait peut-être un
collègue qui était organisé là-bas ou
une de médailles. Non, c'est ça. Ouais,
voilà. Ouais. J'attends de voir. Et les
Ukrainiens ont fait venir des familles
alors que c'est quoi vos sources ? Bah
c'est pour une remise de médaille, c'est
normal.
C'est Andrew Coripko.
Quelle est son interprétation de la
situation ? Ben, il y a trois il y a il
y a il y a trois possibilités. Alors, il
y a le discours des Ukrainiens. Donc,
c'est une combien de morts ? 30 morts.
Ouais, un peu plus. Ouais, il y a une
pauvre gaming y a non, il y a 20 il y a
20 et quelques morts et 80 blessés où il
y a peut-être plus de morts, je sais
plus. Euh parce que des familles, des
gens auxquels on remettait des
décorations, ce qui est normal.
Non, mais je dis pas le contraire mais
donc c'est une du point de vue militaire
russe, ça peut être une cible légitime.
Après, il y a la question de est-ce que
c'est toujours une cible légitime si on
sait qu'il y a des familles autour
? Ça c'est un vrai sujet. Non, mais
c'est un vrai sujet, hein. Je je moi je
suis pas je suis pas l'étatmajor russe,
hein. Je c'est peut-être peut-être ça
peut ça peut être jugé effectivement
comme peut-être un crime de guerre.
C'est c'est c'est exactement ce dont on
vient de parler. Voilà, c'est une cible
légitime. C'est des mecs qui ont
participé à l'incursion à
Coursk, donc qui était assoumis, qui
était c'était un étatmajor tactico
opérationnel et cetera. Il y avait
paraît-il des gens de l'OTAN.
Non, mais paraît-il, ça m'intéresse pas.
Bah dans cette analyse, d'accord. Bah
écoutez, vous y étiez, j'y étais. Non.
Voilà. Donc, on en sait rien à vrai
dire. Donc on en est réduit à des
analyses qui produisent des analyses qui
s'avèrent quand même être assez juste
dans l'ensemble quand on voit l'état du
terrain. Encore une fois, nous avons
sous les yeux comment on fait pour
enquéter sur un crime de guerre ?
Comment on fait pour enquêter sur un
crime de guerre quand ? Dans l'immédiat,
tout de suite, après ? Bah, il faut
documenter, il faut documenter tout, les
victimes, la situation, le moment qui
était là, qui est arrivé avant,
qui quels ont été les ordres
donnés, quels ont été les ordres donnés
et ceux qui et finalement ce qui a été
fait parce que il y a aussi parfois des
ordres qui ne sont pas suivis justement,
mais pas toujours pour le mieux, ça peut
être aussi pour le pire. Pour le pire,
voilà, c'est très compliqué mais il faut
documenter tout ça. Les Russes
d'ailleurs document tous les crimes de
guerre ukrainien depuis 3 ans. Je pense
que les Ukrainens doivent faire la même
chose. Oui, mais il y a beaucoup moins.
Il y a quand même beaucoup moins. Il y
a, je sais plus quel décomte en est
l'ONU
aujourd'hui,
mais pendant longtemps, on était à moins
de 10 ou 11000 morts
civils en Ukraine depuis le 24. De ça,
c'est quoi ? Le NU.
De quelle quelle année ? Et ben 2023, je
dirais. Je dirais ça me va pas. Vous
pensez à 2023 ? Ouais.
Mais j'ai pas la date en tête, je dire
mais c'est un c'est un décomt qu'on peut
trouver. Comment on va faire pour
réconcilier ces deux peuples ?
Ça va être très très très difficile
parce que c'était effectivement des
peuples frères mais là après tout ce qui
s'est passé ça va être très très
difficile. Mais il faut déjà que ça
s'arrête.
Il faut déjà que la population
ukrainienne qui a qui a baissé quasiment
Poutine, il faut lui dire maintenant tu
rentres chez toi, c'est comme ça que ça
va s'arrêter. Ah mais jamais de la vie
ça ça ça
ça voyez ça c'est de l'irréalisme. Ça
c'est poussé à la guerre. Oh non mais on
peut continuer chez toi. Bah oui, il est
en position de force. Enfin depuis quand
quelqu'un qui gagne sur le terrain va
rentrer chez lui s'il rentre chez lui
mais il est mort politiquement parce
qu'il en a eu des morts lui aussi.
Donc il va faire quoi ? Il
va il va dire "Bah oui, j'ai 150000
morts mais voilà, je rentre chez moi
parce que finalement j'avais
tort." Non, c'est c'est ça. C'est tant
qu'on est dans des chimères pareils euh
et bien je
je souffre pour les Ukrainiens parce que
quand même, il y a beaucoup plus
d'Ukrainiens qui meurent que de Russes,
hein. Qu'est-ce qui vous permet
d'affirmer ça ? Euh tous les décomtes
qui ont été faits, vous prenez alors ils
vont jamais vous. Vous prenez alors vous
voulez quoi que je vous donne les les
sources comment dirais-je américaine.
Donc vous prenez McGregor, vous prenez
Larry Johnson, vous
prenez vous prenez Scott Reiter, vous
prenez et encore Scott Reitter, moi je
suis je trouve un peu trop là pour le
coup parfois on se demande s'il est pas
un peu un peu pro russe lui pour le
coup dans certaines de ses analyses.
Non, mais un peu trop, il perd un peu,
il perd un peu sa neutralité, je trouve
de d'analyste justement,
parce que c'est très difficile de la
conserver, surtout quand on va sur le
terrain, il va, il vient, il se balade.
Il y a peut-être du chocolat.
Non, je le pauvre avec ce qui lui est
arrivé après
l'Irak, je sais pas de quoi il vit, mais
ça doit pas être terrible.
Donc après vous
avez vous avez Martianov vous j'aurais
dû vous importer ma liste hein. Je faut
faire comme François Ruffin quand il
vient ici il vient avec
Kelle de note. C'est vrai ? Ouais ouais
il les dépose en en éventail devant lui
et on adore ça parce que il sait que
c'est de la triche ça. Non c'est pas de
la triche
et on a le droit de venir avec ses s et
c'est même c'est même fortement
recommandé. Question internet, vous qui
affirmez voir là où d'autres se voilent
la face. Deux points. Quel conseil sans
langue de bois donneriez-vous aux trois
figures que sont Macron, son premier
ministre et Ursula Vleyen ?
Alors moi, je n'affirme pas voir déjà
voyante hein. Je suis je fais juste de
l'analyse. Euh j'ai beaucoup d'humilité,
beaucoup. Voilà, ce qui est pas le cas
justement de du camp d'en
face. Euh alors, quel conseil
donnerais-je
? Ursula Vleyen ? Je pense
que je pense que je pense qu'elle est
actionnée de l'extérieur. Donc alors ça
c'est gratuit. Oui, c'est gratuit mais
c'est là c'est je n'en sais rien mais je
le pense ou je pense pas que toute seule
elle a ses positions si vous voulez.
aussi.
Oui, je pense qu'elle je pense qu'elle a
un
agenda qui est qui est celui de
l'ancienne administration
américaine.
Euh oui, c'est gratuit. Bah voilà, c'est
gratuit. Alors après notre C'est
gratuit, c'est vous produit. Vous
connaissez le principe ?
C'est c'est ce que je pense. Ensuite, le
premier ministre, notre premier
ministre, je bon, il est responsable de
la défense nationale. Comment il
s'appelle notre premier ministre ? Berou
François
Berou.
Euh
je Ah bon ? J'ai rien à dire sur notre
premier ministre très honnêtement et sur
notre président de la République. Je
pense
que il faudrait
vraiment qu'il ait à cœur la défense de
notre pays. Voilà. Et qu'il quand il dit
quand il dit on aide l'Ukraine pour
défendre l'Europe. Non mais c'est faux.
Pourquoi c'est faux ? Mais la Russie ne
menace pas l'Europe. Enfin, faut arrêter
de raconter n'importe quoi. Et regardez,
si on a besoin de l'Ukraine pour nos
matières premières et tout ça, si les
Russe s'assoit dessus, il nous disent
"Bon ben non, tu t'en vas." Et alors
donc c'est quoi l'idée ? C'est d'aller
reprendre le Donbas. C'est de faire quoi
en fait
? Mais l'Europe n'a pas le début du
commencement et la France n'a pas le
début du com et l'Angleterre n'a pas le
début et personne n'a le début du
commencement de de la moitié d'un
confetti. ce qu'il faudrait pour tenir
une guerre face à la Russie. Enfin,
soyons sérieux, c'est pas des méthodes
ça. C'est pas des méthodes. Si on a
besoin d'énergie, si on a besoin de
matière rare, il faut commencer à
discuter que font les Américains ?
Enfin, ils sont quand même moins moins
imbéciles que nous là. Pour le coup,
Trump, il est en train de discuter,
hein, les terres rares, les machins, le
gaz, le
pétrole, l'entrée massive pour ses
entreprises. Bon, c'est ça, c'est ça qui
va se passer. On va se faire avoir pour
le dire gentiment. Quand on entend les
chancelleries européennes dire "La
Russie est à nos portes, ils ont une
économie de guerre
gigantesque, ils vont aller chercher les
pays baltes." Ils vont aller chercher
les Pays-Baltes. Euh la Pologne
ensuite et vous en pensez quoi ? Je
pense qu'on je pense qu'on à 20 ans,
c'est possible ou pas ? Dans 20 ans ?
Ben ça dépend beaucoup de nous. et nous
quoi. Non mais ça dépend de si on arrête
les frais ou si on si on continue à être
fou quoi. Qu'est-ce qu'on veut ? C'est
bien sûr bien sûr. La Russie peut elle
peut aller prendre des pays européens.
Pourquoi pas ? Peut-être pas peut-être
pas d'ailleurs maintenant dans l'état
actuel de son armée, mais peut-être dans
quelques années. Qui sait ? Mais c'est
pas le sujet. Le sujet c'est qu'il faut
arrêter de faire des manœuvres. Non,
faut arrêter de mettre des bases en
Lituanie comme ça vient d'être fait.
Euh, il faut arrêter de se servir de la
Roumanie et d'empêcher un président qui
ne voulait arrêter la guerre euh de
venir au pouvoir et de de de continuer à
tout faire pour que la Roumanie soit le
faire de lance d'une prochaine offensive
sur la Je faut arrêter quoi. On a dit on
a dit que c'était les Russes qui
faisaient de l'ingérance sur TikTok pour
pousser le président. Oui, mais on l'a
dit beaucoup dit, mais est-ce que ça a
été est-ce que ça a été prouvé ? Parce
que moi j'ai j'ai pas j'ai pas vu de
d'études ou de Ça c'est encore des
déclarations. Ce qui a été clair, c'est
que même notre ambassadeur a a est
intervenu crois. Non, il est intervenu
comment ? lui a emmené des petits pains.
Bah auprès de la commission électorale
qui a décidé que l'élection
roumaine et la candidature de Cline
Gergescour n'était pas valide, valable.
C'est quoi vos sources ?
Euh je peux pas me souvenir de toutes
mes sources chaque fois moi. Euh c'est
sur X. Non mais sur X c'est pas une
source.
C'est sur X qui ?
Gros Roger dans l'Ardèche. Oui, c'est
ça. C'est lui. Bon, encore c'est encore
lui. Question
internet. Donc celle sur l'argent, on
l'a déjà posé.
Euh voilà. Madame Galacteros
comprend-t-elle que la guerre économique
actuelle a débuté en 2014 avec
l'utilisation de l'Ukraine comme un pion
pour couper l'Europe de la Russie et
mettre un terme à tous les partenariats
économiques russo-européens. Entre
parenthèses, une Europe coupée de la
Russie.
n'est plus de n'a plus de contrepoids à
opposer à la géopolitique américaine
fermée la parenthèse. Est-ce que vous
partager la lecture de la question de
Romain ? Sauf la fin, j'ai pas bien
compris la fin. Entre parenthèses, une
Europe coupée de la Russie n'a plus de
n'a plus pour Oui, mais c'est Oui, mais
c'est le c'est le fantasme, c'est le
cauchemar géopolitique américain. Mais
ça fait des années que je le dis, je
peux pas répéter tout chaque fois.
Évidemment, Nordstream, c'est les Russes
qui l'ont fait péter.
Oui, bien sûr. C'est russe oui oui oui.
Qui est-ce qui a fait péter dans stream
? Bah c'est les Américains avec l'aide
des Anglais. Et puis c'est quoi vos
source ? Oh ça c'est
c'est comment il s'appelle ? C'est
l'américain là, il l'a très bien
expliqué. C'est Moch ou
Est-ce que vous avez un sujet qu'on a
pas traité ? Oui mais mais c'est Biden
mes sources puisqu'il l'a annoncé lui,
il l'a même dit. Il a dit "Écoutez, si
jamais NSAM est mise en est mise en
route, euh on le fera sauter." Mais
c'est quand même allemand. Oh mais vous
inquiétez pas, on saura le faire sauter.
Bon ben voilà, ça ça se trouve aussi,
c'est sur YouTube. Est-ce que Est-ce que
vous avez un sujet que vous souhaiteriez
aborder avec nous et notre communauté ?
Plein. Choisissons. Je sais pas. Non, je
je là comme ça vous me prenez au
dépourvu. Mais vous avez peut-être
d'autres questions que vous voulez me
poser. Ah très bon, très bon sujet. Oui,
il y a des bonnes pistaches là-bas. Il y
a des quoi ? Il y a des pistaches
magnifiques.
Euh, l'Iron. Oui. Bombe nucléaire, pas
bombe nucléaire. Comment ça va se passer
si Trump euh va chercher l'Iran ?
Comment ça se passe ? Ah, si Trump va
chercher l'Iran, là c'est la c'est
l'erreur fatidique à ne pas faire là.
s'il se laisse entraîner par Israël et
qu'il arrive à soutenir même
indirectement une attaque
israélienne, là ce
sera ce sera la triple dose de
représail. Voilà, parce que là c'est le
trio
russoiranien qui à un titre un titre ou
un autre ces trois-là sont liés et ils
sont clairement
liés contre les États-Unis pour ça. Pour
l'instant en plus Trump a besoin du D3
de Poutine. Non mais Trump a besoin de
Poutine pour justement pour négocier cet
accord et cetera. Il y a des
négociations qui ont commencé indirect
mais avec de temps en temps des petites
phases directes. Le problème c'est que
l'Iran a dit qu'il n'était pas nucléaire
et même la communauté du renseignement
américain même la communauté du
renseignement américain a dit qu'il
n'avait pas de programme militaire
nucléaire. Et oui, même tout le sigabart
l'avait dit à l'époque avant d'être DNI
et cetera. Donc
euh moi je pense qu'ils sont à ils
peuvent le devenir très très vite.
Voilà, ils ont récemment proposé, je
sais plus si c'est le ministre affaires
étrangères
iranien euh je crois qui a proposé il y
a de tr jours. Mais je c'est tellement
énorme mais en même temps c'est
tellement
vrai. Dénucliser la région. Oui. Oui. Il
a dit "Bah la solution c'est ça, c'est
qu'il y ait plus de parce que la grande
question c'est la question. Moi j'ai été
élevé comme ça, j'ai fait mes études
comme ça. On m'a expliqué au
Moyen-Orient, il y a un équilibre
stratégique. Il y a un équilibre
stratégique parce qu'Israël est
nucléaire et que donc ben ça maintient
l'équilibre stratégique de la dire que
toute la région veut faire la peau
Israël dans le coin quand même, non ?
Oui. Mais quel est le propre de l'arme
nucléaire ?
C'est c'est ce qu'on oublie tout le
temps. C'est une arme de non emploi.
C'est une arme de dissuasion. OK. Les
seuls qui s'autorise finalement à qui
l'ont utilisé, bon, on sait qui c'est.
Et et les seuls qui l'autorisent ou qui
la mettent en service au niveau
tactique, les mini news et cetera, c'est
les
États-Unis. Voilà. Et Israël dit que il
peut le faire aussi éventuellement de
manière préhentive.
Donc on est l'équilibre stratégique, ça
peut être un équilibre entre plusieurs
puissances nucléaires qui se tiennent la
dragéo de chacune. Et c'est comme ça que
le et c'est comme ça que le conçoive un
certain nombre de puissances d'ailleurs.
Et est-ce que alors c'est une bonne idée
diable, est-ce que donner de l'arme
nucléaire à des molins euh qui tabassent
les petites filles c'est peut-être pas
un peu irresponsable.
Alors, quel est le rapport de
nucléariser l'Iran ? C'estàd que si
l'Iran est une puissance nucléaire face
à Israël, est-ce que ça peut pas partir
en queouille très rapidement ?
Bah ou
l'inverse ou l'inverse. Accordons-nous
sur ce désaccord. Non, mais c'est c'est
c'est tout le c'est c'est le processus
dissuasif en lui-même qui mérite d'être
discuté. Question d'internet. Que
pensent-elle des décès de Alex Navalni,
Boris Nepsov ? Evenie Prorigine, Sergey
Scripal en tant que et tant d'autres
opposants en Russie vis-à-vis de la
démocratie.
Alors déjà là, on mélange un peu les les
anciens agents de renseignement et les
dissidents politiques et les opposants
politiques. C'est ça. Ouais. Enfin, il y
a tout. Voilà, c'est bon. D'accord.
Donc, ils sont tous morts. OK. Ils ont
tous en commun. Ils sont morts. Euh, il
est mort. Non, Scripal il est pas mort.
C'est vrai. D'ailleurs, Scripal, il est
pas mort.
Et le nevit de choc dans le slip on pas
est étonnamment inoffensif hein
finalement parce que c'est pas non mais
il a quand même été à l'ostou hein. Oui
mais enfin bon c'est c'est ça devait
être un poison létal mais avec les deux
brê qui visitaient la cathédrale de
Sasbury pour mais ils sont loupés ils
ont cherché à l'attraper et ils sont
loupés. Je sais pas non ils avaient pas
mis le nov dans la couture de son slip.
C'est ça. C'est vous qui le dit. Non ils
sont ils sont loupés. Je ne sais pas,
j'en sais rien. J'en sais
rien. Donc moi, je suis pas là pour dire
si la Russie tue ses opposants, ne les
tue pas et cetera. Il y a beaucoup de
pays dans le monde qui tuent leurs
opposants, qui les font tomber dans les
escaliers ou de plus haut. Euh voilà.
Euh qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je
vous dise ?
Navalni euh j'ai trouvé étonnant que
quelques jours après sa mort, sa
femme plus radieuse que jamais
soit reçu. Ah bah si soit reçu soit reçu
et embrasse comme du bon pain Nancy
Pelosy en lui disant merci. Si moi j'ai
trouvé ça étonnant. Moi moi ça j'ai
trouvé ça étonnant. Alors je me fais la
diable. Elle reçoit un soutien
elle accuse le choc. Elle avait pas
l'air d'accuser le choc. Ouais. Non non,
elle avait surtout l'air d'être mise en
position éventuellement pour prendre la
suite. Mais euh Non, c'est votre
interprétation ? Oui, c'est mon
interprétation.
Alors, je lis la question. Comment
l'invité peut-elle justifier ses propos
négationnistes ? La réalité c'est que la
Russie a non pas envoyé l'Ukraine mais
déclenché des opérations importantes
pour neutraliser les capacités des
forces armées ukrainiennes et les
infrastructures. En point
d'interrogation, question de Martin.
Euh déjà, il faudrait que
Martin soit bien au clair sur ce qu'est
le négationnisme.
Deuxièmement, Martin ne connaît
peut-être pas toute la chronologie des
événements. Martin devrait s'intéresser
à l'offre. Martin demande aussi combien
vous avez de cartes banca de compte
bancaires.
Non mais ça va pas. Possède-elle en
Russie ?
Oui. Donc Martin Martin porte peut-être
un autre nom.
23 MJ45.
Ça peut être intéressant.
de savoir qui est Martin
vraiment. C'est pas Martin
Lours. Euh
donc écoutez, moi je j'ai rien à dire.
que tous ces gens s'intéressent à ce qui
s'est passé euh au mois de février, même
depuis
mi-janvier 2022, tout février jusqu'au
24 février 2022 dans les forces
ukrainiennes, dans les ordres
d'opération, dans le turnover des avions
qui livraient les armements et dans le
début de l'offensive sur le Dombas Bass
pour la reprise du Donbas éclair qui
était prévu par les forces ukrainiennes
et nous derrière à partir du 16 février
et puis après Martin viendra me reposer
des questions. Martin est rabillé pour
l'hiver. Voilà. Euh question de le gris.
Les cyberattaques, c'est pas des
attaques pour elle pour interrogation.
Les hôpitaux verrouillés et
cetera. Attaque sur les numéros
d'urgence et ainsi de suite. Ah bah
peut-être, j'en sais rien. Mais mais
comment voulez-vous que je sache tout ça
? Est-ce que vous voyez euh une s qu'il
y a une guerre hybride. Je vais je vais
rebondir là-dessus. Bien sûr. Est-ce que
vous voyez la Russie tester nos systèmes
d'aide de défense et tester nos
capacités à résister à un bordel
monstrueux ? C'est-à-dire que s'ils font
une frappe préventive, pas préventive,
de répercussion, pas de répercussion, le
fait de s'attaquer à nos numéros
d'urgence pour créer encore plus de
bordel, pour neutraliser notre capacité
à nous coordonner en terme de secours,
en terme de panique, en terme de tout
ça, en terme d'hôpitaux, est-ce que pour
vous c'est un prétest comme ils avaient
fait des exercices pour sortir de Swift,
pour sortir d'Internet, est-ce que pour
eux c'est ça fait partie d'un test d'une
stratégie à grande échelle contre
l'Europe. Mais vous parlez de quoi là ?
De de quelle attaque sur les hôpitaux ?
Mais il a été dit que c'était des
Ukrainiens et des Polonais. Qui est-ce
qui a dit ça ? C'est un c'est même
un Ah punaise !
euh et que cette personne s'intéresse à
ce qui a été apporté sur les origines de
cette attaque. Parce qu'on a on a euh je
sais plus quel responsable français qui
a dit ce serait bien notre ministre des
affaires étrangères mais je suis pas
certaine. Qui a dit c'est les Russes ou
qui a accusé la Russie. Mais non, mais
c'est le président qui a accusé
récemment, qui a qui a expliqué quand il
a dit "On est en guerre et cetera, faut
préparer la guerre là dans les dernières
salve."
C'est-à-dire vous parlez du du de enfin
si on parle de la même chose si vous
parlez des attaques cyberattaques rus
cyberattaques sur les sur les hôpitaux
sur l'hôpital de je ne sais plus où là
de
province il y en a tellement mais il se
passe des choses toutes les 2 heures.
Comment vous comment vous analysez le
fait que Macron va faire envoyer un
petit guide pour résister aux tempêtes
et à la guerre ? C'est ridicule.
Pourquoi les Suédois font ça depuis des
années ? Ils sont en première ligne avec
les Russes. Pourquoi c'est ridicule ?
doigt. À mon avis, ils auraient mieux
fait de rester neutre, hein. Ils doivent
bien avoir la trouille effectivement et
ils ont ils doivent bien regretter
d'être rentrés dans le temps. C'est
comme les Finlandais. Euh alors, je
reviens à ces attaques.
Peut-être la
Russie. Tout à fait. Mais de toute
façon, la Russie considère qu'elle est
attaquée par les forces de l'OTAN. Elle
l'a dit, ses responsables l'ont dit,
l'on le répète toute la sainte journée.
Si on s'intéressait un peu plus, et ça
aussi c'est un gros gros handicap, aux
déclarations, si on suivait, je me
demande qui suit dans nos appareils
d'état les déclarations des responsables
russes depuis 3 ans parce qu'il y en a
quand même hein, il y en a. que Macron
il doit le faire. Mais je ne sais pas,
je ne je n'en suis pas certaine. Je ne
suis pas sûre que tout soit bien
euh que que tout soit bien tracé, bien
évolué, quand qu'on qu'on voilà qu'on
qu'on voit l'évolution du discours,
qu'on voit l'évolution des mots, qu'on
voit qu'on comprenne qu'on du changical,
qu'on comprenne quand il y a eu des euh
des déclarations par exemple de
Caraganov sur le la doctrine nucléaire,
les modifications, tout ça c'est très
important. C'est très important pour
comprendre la posture russe. Non
seulement la posture militaire, mais la
posture mentale, la posture
intellectuel, la manière dont ils
commencent à prendre conscience et
maintenant ils en ont pris carrément
conscience. Maintenant, c'est trop euh
de l'hostilité que nous avons à leur
égard qui qui j'allais dire qui n'a rien
à voir avec l'Ukraine, qui n'a pas
grand-chose à voir avec l'Ukraine. Don
l'Ukraine n'est que l'instrument. Faut
quand même faut quand même se réveiller
là. On est c'est une c'est une guerre
par proxy et nous sommes aussi nous
avons été le proxy de l'administration
Biden. L'Europe est le proxy de
l'administration Biden. Il y a deux
rangs de
proxy. Voilà, il y a une crème premier
rang qui se faitouiller.
Prox proxy ou allié. Enfin allié faut-il
encore une volonté. Oui, les alliés, il
y a une il y a une vague notion quand
même d'égalité ou en tout cas de voix au
chapitre de question internet. Bonsoir
madame Galacterous. Bonsoir madame
Galacterous. A-t-elle une analyse sur la
situation franco-algérienne actuelle ?
Ah !
Alors
euh personnellement, je pense que nous
sommes
euh en grande
partie victime aujourd'hui
euh de notre absence de politique
algérienne, de notre absence de ligne
politique vis-à-vis de
l'Algérie depuis des années et notamment
et très très clairement
Nous sommes nous sommes en fait en train
de subir les représailles algériennes à
la décision de notre président de la
République de reconnaître la marocaité
du Sahara espagnol. Sujet sur lequel
franchement on aurait pu se passer de
prendre partie. Voilà. Voilà. Donc
maintenant les Algériens ils ont beau
jeu de nous tenir la dragé haute et de
nous humilier largam nu.
Question internet. Pourquoi les Suédois
et les Finlandais devraient regretter
leur entrée dans l'OTAN si la Russie
n'est pas n'a pas de vélité
expansionniste ? Mais pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils sont entrés dans l'OTAN ?
Pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ne comprennent
pas que leur neutralité Russ quand même
ils ont l'Ukraine ?
Mais est-ce que est-ce que l'Ukra est-ce
que si on se si on se passe du côté
russe, attendez attendez attendez
attendez attendez attendez, il y avait
peut-être d'autres
moyens s'il se sentait agressé, il y
avait peut-être d'autres moyens qu'
d'aller enfoncer l'Ukraine. Pourquoi ils
ont Pourquoi ils ont pas fait un mur
devant l'Ukraine ? Ils auraient dit à
leurs copains qui parlent russe côté
ukrainien OK, on vous prend, on a un
grand territoire, vous pouvez vous
mettre au chaud chez nous. En attendant
qu'on explique devant les Nations Unies
que ce serait bien d'arrêter de se
sur la gueule et en mesure de
rétorsion guerre économique.
Non mais l'Ukraine enfin c'est c'est un
problème sécuritaire, c'est un problème
militaire en fait parce que c'est à 8
minutes de Moscou en terme de missile
bas. Ben
oui mais oui mais c'est pas c'est pas
une paille, c'est un vrai sujet, ça
change tout. Ça change l'équilibre de la
dissuasion. C'est pour ça que je dis que
ce qui s'est passé le 17 le 17 décembre
oui 2021 quand Poutine a tenté une
dernière fois d'une certaine manière,
c'était la dernière tentative russe euh
de provoquer une remise à plat de la
question de la sécurité
européenne. Les Russes savaient aussi
très bien qu'il y avait déjà des
embryons de base au temps en Ukraine. Il
y en avait deux ou trois qui ont été
tapés dès le début d'ailleurs.
Donc ça mis du temps à sortir le fait
qu'il y avait des bases américaines en
Ukraine. Au départ c'était théorie
comment ils appellent ça ? Du complot.
C'était théorie du complot. Et après
quand le Washington Post Wapo a sorti ça
c'est ça a
été on en parle pas trop en tout cas on
en parle pas dans les médias. On ne peut
pas revenir sur notre narratif. On ne
peut pas. On n'y arrive pas. Voilà. Mais
moi je pense qu'on devrait commencer
parce que ça ça va être trop lourd d'un
seul coup. Ça va être trop lourd quand
Trump va faire un accord. Ah, ça va être
ça va être très très dur pour l'Europe à
tout point de vue, économiquement,
énergétiquement, diplomatiquement,
stratégiquement.
On va payer très cher notre vassalité en
fait et notre et notre incapacité à
changer de parce que les Américains, ils
ont ça de bien, c'est qu'au moins ils
sont capables de prendre des infections,
ils sont capables de retourner le
système, de dire "Bah non, voilà, on
s'est trompé, maintenant on fait comme
ça."
Et Trump clairement il y a il y a il y a
un effet de de lucidité aussi
d'opportunisme parce que il explique que
c'est pas sa guerre, qu'il l'a pas
voulu, que c'est celle de Biden, que lui
il a d'autres sujets, d'autres chats à
fouetter. Euh donc il se donne aussi des
arguments pour pouvoir passer à autre
chose.
Question internet, est-ce que la
Finlande devrait se méfier de la Russie
? Oui. Est-ce que la moitié de l'Europe
devrait être envahie pour la sécurité
russe ? Bien sûr que non. Mais la Russie
n'a besoin d'envahir personne. La
Russie, elle a besoin d'être en
sécurité. Les pays neutres sont des
pays, c'est ça qui est terrible. Et
c'est et c'est à l'image, c'est ça c'est
très important, c'est à l'image du
manikéisme de la pensée stratégique
occidentale. Les pays neutres sont
considérés comme étant dans un trou noir
stratégique qui n'est pas sûr pour eux.
Et donc il faut qu'ils prennent partie,
il faut qu'ils renoncent à leur
neutralité. Or, quand on est entre deux
blocs, c'est-à-dire entre la
Russie avec son arsenal et euh le bloc
de l'OTAN, les pays
neutres, je dirais que c'était les les
vernis du les vernis du du de de de
l'ensemble, si vous voulez, parce que
précisément, ils sont neutres. tant que
l'Ukraine était neutre, tant que
Zelinski n'a n'eû pas dit euh quelques
jours avant le début de la guerre, comme
par hasard, qu'il voulait que son pays
ne soit soit de nouveau nucléaire, qu'il
voulait dénoncer le mémorandum de
Budapest et cetera et cetera, ça allait
très bien ça. On était pas en guerre.
Voilà, eux, ils faisaient une guerre une
guerre civile contre leur propre
population depuis 2014 2015.
Mais l'Ukraine était protégée. À partir
du moment où elle a accepté ce que lui
ont proposé les États-Unis et les
Anglais, c'estàd la faire rentrer dans
le temps et pour cela de faire une
guerre ainsi que l'a très bien expliqué
Arestovic,
euh c'est là qu'elle s'est mise en
danger. Donc il faut retrouver la
neutralité de l'Ukraine. C'est c'est
vital en fait pour
l'Ukraine. C'est pour ça que tout le
discours européen sur le thème non, on
ne ferme pas tout à fait la porte et
cetera. Maintenant, c'est les Américains
qui disent "Non, c'est bon, c'est
terminé là, c'est c'est plié le temps
là, c'est fini." Voilà. Game over. Game
over. Voilà. Est-ce que vous avez trois
livres à conseiller à notre communauté
? Guerre et paix.
Oui, venez me venez m'écouter, même ceux
qui trouvent que je suis je ne sais
quoi, venez écouter, ça vous ça vous ça
vous détendra, vous verrez. Tous les
tous les mercredis 19h monondoscopie,
c'est demain. Euh alors euh tr livres.
Alors trois livres. Ouais, j'aurais dû
penser à ça, c'est vrai. Euh trois
livres actuels, pas obligatoire, hein.
Obligatoirement. Bah le grand
échiquier de Sbini Brezinski,
euh la guerre hors
limite des deux Chinois dont j'ai oublié
le nom des colonels, qui est sorti
quelques années après, qui est non qui
est sorti en 2006, peut-être en français
mais qui date d'un peu avant.
Euh qu'est-ce qu'il y a d'intelligent à
lire ? Le dernier livre de Bruno Lemè.
Oui. Non.
Non. Euh si vous voulez avoir une idée
de virus à genou, si vous voulez alors
c'est un
roman euh écrit par Julian
Oda et que j'ai trouvé intéressant à
lire justement pour s'imprégner un peu
culturellement euh de ce que peut-être
la mentalité russe sur la guerre, sur la
mort, sur plein de choses. C'est le mage
du
créelin. Voilà. Et ça ça se lit comme
ça. C'est une c'est un roman. C'est
c'est l'histoire romancée d'un des
principaux euh spin doctor, on va dire,
de Vladimir Poutine. Voilà.
Vous connaissez Franck Bianquier ? Non.
Erasmus, ça vous parle ? Le programme ?
Euh oui. C'est mon époque. CIT l'époque
de Casimè aussi ça. Est-ce que vous avez
un conseil pour les jeunes générations ?
Une bouteille à la mer, quelque chose
qui restera impérissable.
Apprendre des
langues. Apprendre des langues. Faire de
la philosophie, faire de
l'histoire. Bah
langzo assimile, je sais pas du lingo.
Ah bah voyager, voyager,
voyager. Voilà. Apprendre des langues.
Qu'est-ce que j'ai dit ? Faire de
l'histoire et de la philosophie. Voilà.
Caroline Gcteros, merci. Je vous en
prie.
[Musique]